What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Searchlight Pictures presents
有什么比在烤架上滋滋作响、大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由 Instacart 采购员精心挑选并送到你门口的、在烤架上滋滋作响、大理石纹理完美的肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开戏水池就能下单的完美肋眼牛排。不管你的夏天需要采购什么杂货，Instacart 都能满足你。下载 Instacart 应用，前三单即可享受零配送费。服务费、排除条款和适用条款均适用。Instacart，超值交付的杂货。Searchlight Pictures 出品
The Roses, only in theaters August 29th. From the director of Meet the Parents and the writer of Poor Things Comes The Roses, starring Academy Award winner Olivia Coleman, Academy Award nominee Benedict Cumberbatch,
电影《The Roses》，8月29日仅在影院上映。本片由《拜见岳父大人》导演与《可怜的东西》编剧联袂打造，奥斯卡奖得主奥利维娅·科尔曼、奥斯卡奖提名者本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇领衔主演，
Andy Samburg, Kate McKinnon, and Allison Janney. A hilarious new comedy filled with drama, excitement, and a little bit of hatred, proving that marriage isn't always a bed of roses. See The Roses,
安迪·萨姆伯格、凯特·麦金农和艾莉森·珍妮倾情加盟。这是一部充满戏剧性、兴奋感和一点点恨意的爆笑新喜剧，证明了婚姻并不总是一帆风顺。敬请走进影院，
only in theaters, August 29th. Get tickets now. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0.
观赏《The Roses》，8月29日全国影院上映。立即购票。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，也是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士 6.0》。
Hello, everybody. Hey there. Okay, so by the time you are. listening to this, I will be in Chicago. Chicago! I will be in rehearsals for my play, Ashland Avenue. Woo! Now, something we want you all to know is that we really did our best to record a bunch of Office Office Lady's 6.0 episodes and second drinks ahead of time, so there wouldn't be any kind of like big break in our schedule while I went to do this play. We truly did, you guys. We worked our butts off to make as many new episodes as we could. And here's the thing, Jenna, I feel like you need to
大家好。你们好。好的，所以当你们听到这一期节目的时候，我应该已经在芝加哥了。芝加哥！我将为我的话剧《阿什兰大道》进行排练。哇！现在，我们要让大家知道的一件事是，我们真的尽了最大努力提前录制了一堆《办公室女士 6.0》的节目和“第二杯饮品”节目，这样当我去做这部话剧时，我们的日程就不会出现任何大的空档。我们真的做到了，各位。为了制作尽可能多的新节目，我们拼尽了全力。事情是这样的，珍娜，我觉得你需要
explain your rehearsal schedule for this play because it's so intense. And you were explaining it to me. And my first thought was, there's no way that you can be recording a podcast while you're in these rehearsals. Where are you going to do it? From the bathroom? Yeah, I mean, okay, so we rehearse six days a week. It's Tuesdays through Sundays from 10 a.m. to 7 p.m. Are you loopy by the end? You are. Yes, you are. You only get one day off, which is Mondays. And that's true. when you're in performances as well. You do eight shows a week. Mondays are off. And of course, you know, when we're not in the room rehearsing together, you're expected to be like memorizing your lines, going over your work from that day, coming up with new questions for the next day.
解释一下你这部话剧的排练日程，因为它太紧凑了。你之前跟我解释过。我的第一反应是，在这样的排练强度下，你根本不可能录制播客。你要在哪里录？从浴室里录吗？是的，我的意思是，好吧，我们每周排练六天。从周二到周日，早上10点到晚上7点。排练到最后你脑子会转不动吗？会的。是的，会的。你只有一天休息时间，那就是周一。而且等你开始正式演出时也是这样的。你每周要演八场。周一休息。当然，你知道的，当我们不在排练室一起排练时，你还得背台词、复习当天的进度、为第二天想出新的问题。
There's also like press obligations to get the word out about the play. And of course, being a mom, all those things. And you know, at first I thought, well, I'll just, I can do it all. I'll just do it all. Because that's what we do. We all are like that, y'all. We're all like, we got this. Yeah. But when I physically was handed my schedule and I read it, I was like, oh, shit, basically. Not to mince words. Well, you know, I remember what it was like when I was doing my Hallmark Christmas movie.
还有宣传这部话剧的通告任务。当然，还要当一个妈妈，所有这些事情。你知道，起初我想，好吧，我能搞定这一切。我什么都能应付。因为这就是我们的风格。大家都是这样的，朋友们。我们都会觉得，没问题，我们能行。是的。但当我亲手拿到日程表并阅读它时，我的第一反应基本上就是，哦，操。话糙理不糙。嗯，你知道，我还记得我拍 Hallmark 圣诞电影时的情景。
It was all consuming. I mean, I had an hour drive. I got up real early, had an hour drive, got to the set. I was in every single scene. That's how you are in this play. You're in the whole thing. And then by the time I would get home, I would literally just roll right into bed. Yeah, I mean, the etiquette of doing a play is like if you aren't actively rehearsing, if you're not up there blocking, you sit and watch your other actors because you're all living and breathing the story of the play.
那真是耗尽了我的一切。我是说，我要开车一个小时。起得很早，开了一个小时车，到达片场。我在每一场戏里都有份。你在这部话剧里也是这样。你每一场都有戏。然后等我回到家，基本上就是直接瘫倒在床上。是的，我的意思是，演话剧的规矩就是，如果你没有在排练，如果你没有在台上走位，你就得坐下来看其他演员表演，因为你们都在共同经历和呼吸着话剧的故事。
So, yeah, I think there's like one scene that I'm not in. I have to sit there. You have to learn the whole world. That's part of the process. So, yes, lady, when I showed you my schedule, you were wonderful. You were like lady? This is what we do for each other. We have to have a talk.
所以，是的，我想大概只有一场戏是没有我的。但我得坐在旁边看。你必须了解整个世界。这是过程的一部分。所以，是的，女士，当我把日程表给你看时，你太棒了。你就像，女士？这就是我们为彼此做的事。我们得谈谈。
You guys move things around so I could go off to Vancouver and do that movie. This is what we do. And just another reason why I'm so thankful for this podcast in this office lady's family we've built. Well, you said, and I'm so grateful to you, you said, lady, you need to take this space. You need to press pause on some things and take this space. And I want to say a big thank you to you, Cassie, for working so hard to plan ahead. And Sam, thank you for all of our double recording weeks. Cassie and Sam, you've been doing all this extra editing.
你们调整了各种安排，我才能去温哥华拍那部电影。这就是我们一直在做的事。这也是我如此感激这个播客以及我们建立的“办公室女士”大家庭的又一个原因。嗯，你说过，我非常感激你，你说，女士，你需要给自己留出空间。你需要把某些事情按下暂停键，给自己留出空间。我要对卡西大声说声谢谢，感谢你为提前规划付出了这么多努力。还有萨姆，谢谢你陪我们度过所有的双倍录制周。卡西和萨姆，你们做了所有这些额外的剪辑工作。
Oh, my goodness. Okay, here's the thing. And I'm going to just get a little emotional. But you guys know that getting back on stage has been a bucket list item for me. And I kind of figured I would just wait until my kids, were up and out of high school before I took that next big acting project, you know. But after everything I went through, you just kind of realized that life is short and that things can change at any moment.
天哪。好的，事情是这样的。我要稍微有点情绪激动了。但你们知道，重新回到舞台上一直是我人生清单上的一个愿望。我原本以为，要等到我的孩子们长大并高中毕业后，我才会去接手下一个重大的表演项目，你知道的。但在经历了这一切之后，你就会明白生命苦短，事情随时可能发生改变。
Yeah. And while I am not worried about kicking the bucket, I saw the bucket. Mm. And it really put my life in focus. And when this opportunity came along, I thought I want to do it now. So I'm very grateful to you guys to our office ladies community. for helping me take the space to do this thing that I really needed to do for my soul. Yeah.
是的。虽然我不担心自己会“归西”，但我确实看到了那个“棺材”。嗯。这真的让我看清了生活。当这个机会出现时，我心想，我现在就要去做。所以我非常感激你们，感激我们的“办公室女士”社区，感谢你们帮我腾出空间来做这件我内心真正需要去做的事。是的。
Thank you. Of course. I mean, I think there's going to be moments in our lives, especially in our work-life together, where there are going to be those moments. Yeah. I know what this means to you. I know what it means to you. It gave me nothing but joy to make this space for you.
谢谢。当然。我的意思是，在我们的生活中，尤其是在我们共同的工作生活中，肯定会有这样的时刻。是的。我知道这对你意味着什么。我知道这有多大意义。为你腾出这个空间，除了快乐，我没有别的感受。
I gave it so wholeheartedly. You did that for me. Look, homework Christmas movie. I know some people would be like, oh, oh, it's something. a Hallmark movie. But I never got to be number one on a call sheet. I never got to have that, I don't know, sense of worth in that way to a huge project. Yeah. And you saw that I needed that and you made that space for me, but I would happily do it again. I would happily do it for Sam, for Cassie. Cassie, when you make the WNBA, I will come to all your games. I will be the mascot.
我完全是全心全意地这么做的。你以前也为我做过。听着，那个 Hallmark 圣诞电影。我知道有些人会觉得，哦，哦，那只是一部 Hallmark 电影。但我从来没有在演职员表里排过第一位。我从来没有在这样一个大项目中获得那种，我不知道，那样的自我价值感。是的。而你看到了我对此的需求，你为我腾出了空间，但我很乐意再次这样做。我很乐意为萨姆、为卡西这样做。卡西，等你打进 WNBA 的时候，我会去你的每一场比赛。我会当你的吉祥物。
And Sam, Sam, I was just talking to Josh about you, and he was saying how much he enjoys whenever you pop on the podcast and what a great voice you have. What a great presence you have. When Jen and I went and did the SHRM conference, we mentioned you. The audience applauded at the mention of your name. Oh, thank you. And anyway, we're a team effort here. Yeah. And I'm thankful for it.
还有萨姆，萨姆，我刚才还在和乔什谈起你，他说他非常喜欢你偶尔在播客里出声，而且你的声音太棒了。你的存在感太强了。我和珍娜去参加 SHRM 大会时提到了你。观众一提到你的名字就鼓掌了。哦，谢谢。不管怎样，我们这里是一个团队。是的。我对此非常感激。
And we're so happy we could do this for you. Well, the reason that I just shared all of that today is that in order to help with this goal of giving me the space, today we are going to run an interview that I did with David Spade and Dana Carvey for their podcast, Fly on the Wall. And lady, I love these guys. I love them too. I follow their podcast Instagram. I love it. I love their podcast. And I was so giddy that I got to do this interview. Angela, you were supposed to do it with me, but you booked the AT&T commercial. I know. And I was so bombed. They asked me, me my availability, and I only had one day where I said I had a conflict, and that was the day
我们很高兴能为你做这些。好吧，我今天分享这一切的原因是，为了协助实现给我留出空间这个目标，今天我们将播放一段采访，这是我为大卫·斯佩德和达纳·卡维的播客节目《墙上苍蝇》接受的采访。女士，我太喜欢这几个家伙了。我也很喜欢他们。我关注了他们播客的 Instagram。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢他们的播客了。能做这次采访，我兴奋得有点眩晕。安吉拉，你本该和我一起去的，但你接了 AT&T 的广告。我知道。我当时太沮丧了。他们问我有没有空，我只有一个日子说我有冲突，那就是我们拍摄的那天。
we filmed. I know. And so I missed fly on the wall, but I'm so excited for people to hear it. This is such a great interview, and it just sounded like you had such a great time. Oh, my gosh. Well, I've known David Spade casually for years. There was even this rumor for a little while that we had dated. But in fact, we had never met. And we finally did meet. And I was like, oh, hey, how are you, my boyfriend? And we laughed about this, and it was very, very funny. I was so wanting to ask him, there's a lore in my neighborhood, and I don't know if it's true. Okay. That David Spade once purchased my house that I live in.
我知道。所以我错过了《墙上苍蝇》，但我真的很为听到它的人感到兴奋。这是一次非常棒的采访，听起来你玩得太开心了。天哪。其实我和大卫·斯佩德泛泛之交好多年了。有一段时间甚至有传言说我们在约会。但事实上，我们从未见过面。我们终于见面时，我心想，哦，嗨，你好啊，我的“男朋友”？我们还拿这个开玩笑，非常非常好笑。我当时特别想问他，我社区里流传着一个传说，我不知道是不是真的。好吧。大卫·斯佩德曾经买下了我现在住的房子。
What? Yes, for his mother. And I don't know if it's true or not. That's not who I bought my house from. But one of my neighbors told me, oh, yeah, you know, David Spade bought your house one time years ago. For his mom. I was so excited to ask him that, but, you know, next time. Well, you got to go on.
什么？是的，是买给他妈妈的。我不知道这是真是假。我的房子可不是从他那儿买的。但我的一个邻居告诉我，“哦，对啦，你知道吗，大卫·斯佩德多年前买过你的房子。”买给他妈妈的。我当时特别想问他这个，不过，好吧，下次吧。嗯，你得上节目。
They're great. And, you know, I had never met Dana Carvey, but I just know how much Steve Carrell loved him. Because Steve worked on the Dana Carvey show. And Steve would tell us stories about how amazing Dana was. And so one of the coolest things was after this interview, Dana stayed on the Zoom with me for like 30 minutes. Get out. And we chatted. and I did not want it to end.
他们太棒了。而且，你知道，我以前从未见过达纳·卡维，但我深知史蒂夫·卡瑞尔有多么喜爱他。因为史蒂夫曾在《达纳·卡维秀》工作过。史蒂夫经常给我们讲达纳有多么了不起的故事。所以最酷的事情之一就是，采访结束后，达纳在 Zoom 上陪了我大约 30 分钟。别开玩笑了。我们一直在聊天。我真不想结束。
It's like a highlight of my life that I got to have this conversation with him. Yes, I mean, I'm a big Saturday Night Live nerd. I love all those guys. Me too. But listen, I really hope you enjoy the interview. We talk about all kinds of stuff. We talk about the office and Saturday Night Live.
能和进行这样一番对话，简直是我人生中的高光时刻。是的，我的意思是，我是个狂热的《周六夜现场》书呆子。我喜欢所有人。我也是。不过听着，我真的希望你们能喜欢这次采访。我们聊了各种各样的事情。我们聊了《办公室》和《周六夜现场》。
And thank you all again. But wait, you have to tell everyone how to get tickets to your show. Oh, yes. Okay, you can go to Goodmantheater.org, and the play is called Ashland Avenue and Preview Start, September 6th. I'm going. You sure are. Yay! Thank you. All right, here is Jenna on Fly on the Wall. Summer is Tim's ice latte season. It's also hike season, pool season, picnic season, and yeah, I'm down season. So drink it up with Tim's ice lattes, now whipped for a smooth taste. Order yours
再次谢谢大家。等等，你还得告诉大家怎么买你话剧的票。哦，对的。好吧，你可以访问 Goodmantheater.org，这部话剧叫《阿什兰大道》，9月6日开始预演。我要去。你当然要去。耶！谢谢。好的，接下来是珍娜在《墙上苍蝇》上的访谈。夏天是蒂姆冰拿铁的季节。这也是远足季、游泳季、野餐季，以及“好吧，我随时奉陪”的季节。所以，快来畅饮蒂姆冰拿铁，现已打发至丝滑口感。今天就在蒂姆应用上订购，
on the Tim's app today at participating restaurants in Canada for a limited time. Risk is the podcast where people tell true stories they never thought they dare to share, like our episode After All, where Ken Cole and Tom Ballet share about the night their son had a psychotic break. And at that point, I didn't actually know I had been stabbed all over my arm. I was in shock. Find the Risk episode After All on the free Odyssey app or wherever you get your podcast. David, Jenna Fisher.
参与活动的加拿大餐厅限时供应。《风险》是一个人们讲述他们从未想过敢于分享的真实故事的播客，比如我们的单集《毕竟》，肯·科尔和汤姆·巴莱在其中讲述了他们的儿子精神崩溃的那天晚上。“当时，我其实并不知道我的整条胳膊都被刺伤了。我当时处于休克状态。”在免费的 Odyssey 应用或你获取播客的任何地方收听《风险》的单集《毕竟》。大卫，珍娜·费舍尔。
Jenna Fisher, the lovely Jenna Fisher, who's pretty universally liked out there. I mean, very sweet, very talented, very fun and charming. Famous for the office. She's done a lot of movies and a lot of other things, but she was Pam on the office, the smash. For all 98 seasons. Yeah.
珍娜·费舍尔，可爱的珍娜·费舍尔，在外界几乎受到了普遍喜爱。我是说，非常甜美，非常有才华，非常有趣迷人。因《办公室》而闻名。她拍过很多电影和其他作品，但她在《办公室》里饰演帕姆，那个轰动之作。演了整整98季。是的。
That show just kept. grinding it out and uh yeah there's a spinoff now we talk about um we don't only talk about the office of course we have she does plays she's doing a new one we're talking about she talks about i asked her about nick swartz and about will feral she loves SNL and uh i hit her up after the interview and uh you know i think she had what we had she's always like she's like exactly we say did we ask the right questions was i interesting was i fun and we always finish and going i think we did that wrong whatever but she's very sweet about it she wanted to do a good job she listens to the show she has her own show um the office ladies um and she uh she tells some really
那个节目一直在努力坚持，而且，是的，现在有个衍生剧了。我们谈论了，嗯，我们不仅谈论《办公室》，当然，她还演话剧，她正在排演一档新话剧，我们聊了，她谈到了，我问了她关于尼克·斯瓦茨和威尔·法瑞尔的事，她很喜欢《周六夜现场》，而且，我在采访后联系了她，而且，你知道，我觉得她跟我们有同感，她总是这样，她会说，就像我们说的，我们问对问题了吗？我有意思吗？我好玩吗？我们每次结束时都会说，我觉得我们那段没做好，随便啦，但她对此真的很甜美，她想把工作做好，她听这个节目，她有自己的节目——《办公室女士》，而且她讲了一些非常
funny stories interesting stories about her struggles before she got on the office and there's a whole arc of story involving molly shannon and that's a very interesting thing yeah and sometimes when that we finish the podcast we keep our laptop up open. So I ended up talking with her for a half hour afterwards. She's very easy. Well, she's easy to talk to. So anyway, I hope you enjoy this one. Jenna Fisher. I was just Aspire producer, and it's a profound question. When you're driving around, a long drive, two-hour drive, whatever. What's your entertainment? XM News, music, pop.
有趣的故事，关于她在加入《办公室》之前的挣扎的有趣故事，其中还有一个围绕莫莉·香农的完整故事线，这是一个非常有趣的部分。是的，有时候播客录完后，我们还开着笔记本电脑。所以我最后和她聊了半个小时。她很容易相处。我是说，她很好沟通。所以不管怎样，希望你们会喜欢这一期。珍娜·费舍尔。我只是个有抱负的制作人，这是一个深刻的问题。当你开车到处跑，长途开车，两小时的车程，什么的。你的娱乐活动是什么？XM新闻、音乐、流行播客，还是只是挂断电话，回电话？你有10秒钟。哦，不是音乐。我不听音乐。我的第一辆车没有能用的收音机，我只是习惯了在安静中开车。这是我的首选。但现在我会说是新闻、播客或电话。所以我很喜欢这种理念，就是你 literally 可以直接像，就安安静静的，两小时，三小时，就是，天哪。
podcasting, or just wrap, phone calls to pay back. You have 10 seconds. Ooh, it's not music. I do not listen to music. My first car did not have a working radio, and I just got used to driving in silence. And it's my preference. But now I would say news, podcasts, or phone calls. So I love the idea that you literally could go like just the silence, two hours, three hours, just, Jesus.
安静。天哪，太折腾了。顺便说一句，这很健康。我不知道。我从密苏里州圣路易斯一路开到加利福尼亚，车里没有收音机。只有开着的车窗。而且也没有空调。我的第一辆车真的只是，它只是把你从一个地方带到另一个地方。
Silence. Jesus, it's chasing. It's healthy, by the way. I don't know. I drove from St. Louis, Missouri all the way to California with no radio. Just open windows. Also, no air conditioning. My first car was really just, it just moved you from one place to another.
里面没有任何奢侈可言。不是那种老式的，比如带空调。但，是的，什么年份的车？我不记得了。我想大概是86年的车吧。我是说，它刚造出来的时候，原本是有这些功能的。只是它们不再起作用了。所以你拍了《办公室》，赚了那么多钱，然后你买了一辆1988年的二手别克？
There was no luxury involved in the same. Not old, like air conditioning. But yeah, what year of car? I don't remember. I think it was like an 86. I mean, it had originally, when it was built, had these features. They just didn't work anymore. So you do the office, all those years, and then you buy a used Buick from 1988?
我的意思是，如果非得这样，我会跟卡瑞尔谈谈的。不。我要打电话给格雷格·丹尼尔斯。好吧，你打吧。不，不，不。所以当时我有一辆马自达323两厢车。那就是我开着横跨全国的车。好吧。
I mean, I'll talk to Corel if I have to. No. I'm going to call Greg Daniels. Okay, go ahead. No, no, no. So I had a Mazda 323 hatchback. And that was the car I drove across the country. Okay.
然后我升级成了一辆大众捷达，那可能是我拥有过的最喜欢的车。太棒了。但后来当我拿到《办公室》的大笔片酬时，我买了一辆蠢车。好吧。是的，劳斯莱斯。那是，我走进一家梅赛德斯奔驰的经销商，他们有一辆小型轿车。他们只生产了大约七辆这种车。它拥有赛车的发动机，
And then I upgraded to a Volkswagen Jetta, which was my favorite car maybe I've ever had. It was awesome. But then when I got my big office paycheck, I got a stupid car. Okay. Yeah, Rolls Royce. It was, I walked into a Mercedes dealership and they had a little sedan. They only made like seven of these. and it had like the engine of a race car
但装在 C 级奔驰的车身里，所以它看起来既可爱又紧凑，但我百分之百是个混蛋司机，因为我可以超过去任何人，我可以，哦，太棒了。你一直留着它吗？我租的，租约到期后我就退了。租赁的。
but in like the body of like a C-class Mercedes so it was like cute and compact but it I was a hundred percent an asshole driver like because I could cut around anyone I could it was oh it was great Did you keep it? I leased it and I gave it up after the lease. Lease.
然后我变得更务实了。我们都有这样的故事。你想让我先说吗，大卫？因为这跟你的有点像。好吧，有了一点钱，拍了部电影什么的，有了多余的钱。去了奔驰经销商。哦，天哪。一辆小巧的敞篷奔驰轿跑车，就像，哦，哇，这太棒了。
And I went more practical. We all have that story. You want me to go first, David? Because it's similar to yours. Okay, got a little money, some movie, whatever, got extra money. Went to a Mercedes dealership. Oh, my God. A convertible little Mercedes-Coop, like, oh, wow, this is awesome.
开了三四天后发现，当我把顶棚升起来时，我是透过后面的塑料挡风玻璃看外面的。所以把它退了，换成了一辆 SLE 或 420 SLE。然后我开始吸引人们的注意，我住在山谷里，当我经常去 7-Eleven 或加油站时。所以我后来去了本田。我只是想要一辆低调的车。这就是我的故事。
Drove it for three or four days and realized when I had the canopy up, I was looking through a plastic windshield in the back. So took it back, traded it in for SLE or a 420 SLE. And then I started getting people paying attention. to me, I lived in the valley when I would go to like 7-Eleven or a gas station. So then I went to Honda. I just wanted a low-fied car. That's my story.
好吧，洛杉矶的问题在于，你买了一辆超棒的车，然后你在里面只能开到每小时32英里，因为你总是被堵在路上。所以有点像几年后，我就想，哦，我能做的最好的事情也就是猛踩油门冲上匝道。是的，300马力。然后这就，完全是这样。是的。我搬出去的时候，拿到第一笔片酬时买了个东西，当时我没有车。所以我买了一辆车。达纳知道这个故事。6000美元的本田。我没有买太显眼的。我只有6000块。然后我把它开到即兴表演俱乐部，然后我把它停好。我带我的哥们出来给他看，结果它被偷了。什么？所以多久？你才开了一晚，一天。你去了一个地方。
Well, the problem with L.A. is that you get this awesome car and then you can only go like 32 miles an hour in it because you're always stuck in traffic. So it's kind of like after a few years, I was like, oh, the best I can do is like whip down the on ramp. Yeah, 300 horsepower. And then that's, exactly. Yeah. When I moved out, I got something when I first paycheck and I went and I had no car. So I got a car. Dana knows this story. $6,000 Honda. I didn't go flashy. I only had six. And then I drove it to the improv and then I brought it out. I brought my buddy out to show him and it was stolen. What? So how long? You had it for like a night one day. You went one place.
还有凯文·内龙。开着一辆诡异地相似的车。我不是说他和这起抢劫案有什么关系，但这确实有点诡异。但我的第一辆车是一辆大众甲壳虫。你是要说第一辆车，还是拿到额外片酬时的第一辆车？我？不，你。我们知道你的故事。
And Kevin Neon. And drove a car, eerily similar to that. I'm not saying he had anything to do with the robbery, but it was kind of weird. But my first car was a Volkswagen bug. Are you going to go to first car or first car when you got an extra paycheck? Me? No, you are. We know your story.
我们知道我的故事。大卫，你买的。哦，我有过不少车，因为我确实喜欢车，但我，我的脖子经常出毛病。所以每次我买一辆我喜欢的车，它一开始，就太痛苦了。就像珍娜说的，当你在那一整天走走停停时，这不像你住在中西部，你可以踩死油门，而且有很大的停车场。比如你在亚利桑那州的温迪汉堡，那里大概有300个停车位。而你来到这里，Kmart 只有一个车位。然后你心想，我们所有人都要共用这个吗？
We know my story. David, you got. Oh, I had my fair share because I do like cars, but I, my neck gives me trouble. So every time I get a car, I love, it just starts, it's just too painful. And like Jenna said, when you're starting and stopping all day, it's not like you live in the Midwest and you can floor it and there's big parking lots. Like when you go to Wendy's in Arizona, there's like 300 parking spots. And when you go here, there's one at Kmart. And you go, are we all sharing this?
你简直不敢相信当你来到洛杉矶时。车位有多少，有些商业场所根本没有停车位。所以我不知道我们该怎么办。这有点把我难住了。我意识到我不需要那些又大又豪华的车。我只需要告诉别人我有就行了。我其实并不需要它们。我的第一辆车也是手动挡的。
You can't believe when you get to L.A. How little, there's some businesses have absolutely no parking. So I don't know what we're supposed to do. So that kind of threw me. And I realized they didn't need big fancy cars. I could just tell people I had them. I didn't really need them. My first car was also manual transmission.
哦，天哪。在洛杉矶开一整天车下来，我的左脚真的会酸痛。因为根本没有，你一直在三档和四档之间来回切换。根本没有，你在这辆车里根本挂不到五档。天哪，现在没人开手动挡了。没有。这是一种，你知道，这是最便宜的车。就像，手动挡是最便宜的车。我爸爸非常务实。他当时说，你会买这辆车。我教你怎么开。这就是你所需要的。你不需要任何花哨的东西。是的，在圣路易斯。
Oh, boy. And my left foot would, like, truly ache at the end of, like, driving all day in L.A. Because there was, you were constantly just going, like, in and out of third and fourth gear. There was, like, you never made it to fifth gear in this car. God, no one has a stick anymore. No. It's a, you know, this was the cheapest car. Like, the manual.
是的。你一定去过圣路易斯。我要去圣路易斯演出。海瑟，那个城市叫什么名字？圣路易斯的 Imo's 比萨？让我们看看她有没有听说过。圣路易斯的 Ino's 比萨？没有。
transmission was the cheapest car. My dad's very practical. He was like, you'll get this car. I'll teach you how to drive it. This is all you need. You don't need any frills. Yeah. In St. Louis.
但我挺喜欢这个镇子的。我喜欢到处走走。我喜欢体育场离得很近，你知道的。珍娜，你知道切斯特菲尔德是什么吗？切斯特菲尔德是我长大的地方。哦，真的吗？切斯特菲尔德是我家人现在住的地方。
Yeah. You've been to St. Louis, I bet. I'm going to St. Louis to a show. Heather, what is the city call? In Mose Pizza in St. Louis? Let's see if she's heard of it. Inos pizza in St. Louis? No.
噢。是的，我其实是在曼彻斯特和切斯特菲尔德之间的未建制区长大的。不过，是的，肯定是切斯特菲尔德。为什么？因为那是我的巡演要去的地方。他们说伊尔丝这周末和妮基·格拉泽一起在圣路易斯演出，她问，为什么他们不把你的巡演地点设在圣路易斯？没人去，那是切斯特菲尔德。我说，哦，我不知道。我甚至都不知道我要去哪。我的意思是，如果你来自圣路易斯，你就会知道
But I like it as a town. I like walking around. I like that stadiums are really close. close in, you know. Jenna, do you know what Chesterfield is? Chesterfield is where I grew up. Oh, is it really? Chesterfield is where my family lives now.
切斯特菲尔德是什么。是的，这不像，是的，这不是市中心。我的意思是，圣路易斯是市中心。你要去的是郊区。你在郊区。我对此完全没意见。而且我觉得那是个好地方。我以前去过。我觉得挺新的。不管怎样，我们会为你高中认识的每个人准备好免费票。除此之外。太棒了。太棒了。嘿。注意你的言辞。我的高中女同学会来看你的演出。超级好玩。我和达纳有个问题。首先，我要告诉达纳一个小问题，你不知道。好吧。让我们尽量让我们的嘉宾保持清醒。比如问一些她不常被问到的问题。哦，耶。我们是来围观的。她会被搞得晕头转向的。我喜欢这个。
Uh-oh. Yeah, I actually grew up in like Manchester slash Chesterfield in an unincorporated area. But yeah, Chesterfield, for sure. Why? Because that's where I'm going for my tour. And they said ICE was with Nikki Glazer this weekend. from St. Louis, and she goes, why don't they put on your tour St. Louis? No one, it's Chesterfield. I go, oh, I don't know. I don't even know what I'm going. I mean, if you're from St. Louis, you know what
太棒了。每个人在采访中都喜欢这样。我本来想和达纳一起做这个，然后我打了电话给珍娜，对吧，珍娜？你还记得吗？是的，当然。是的。而且你人非常好。你接了电话，还给我大致讲了它是怎么运作的以及你是怎么做的。这确实给了我一些鼓舞，让我觉得这可能挺有意思的。
Chesterfield is. Yeah, it's not like, yeah, it's not downtown. I mean, St. Louis is downtown. You're going to be in the burbs. You're in the suburbs. That's fine with me. And I think it's a great place. I've been there before. I think it's new. Anyway, we'll set up comps for everyone you know from high school. Other than that. Great. Great. Hey. Be careful what you say. My high school ladies are going to come out for your show. It's super fun. Dana and I had a question. First of all, I'll tell Dana a little pre-question that you don't know. All right. Let's try to keep our guests off balance. Like with questions, she's not asked all the time. Oh, yeah. We're here to watch. She's going to come out here to dizzy. I love it.
如果必须这样做的话，达纳，那就必须这样做。没关系。随便吧。然后达纳提出了一个问题：你真的需要一个搭档吗？你脑子里有没有闪过这样的念头？我本可以自己单干，这样钱就翻倍了。你脑子里有过这种想法吗？
Great. Everyone loves that in an interview. I thought of doing this with Dana and then I called Jenna, right, Jenna? Do you remember this? Yes, of course. Yes. And you were very sweet. You took the call and you kind of walked me through how it works and what you did. And it really gave me a little boost to say this might be fun.
或者也许找安吉拉。但是……我和达纳整天都在想这个，天天都在想。人们总是没完没了地问我们为什么。你知道，为什么是我们？为什么是现在？你们真的是朋友吗？你们经常被这么问吗？
And if it has to be, Dana, it has to be. That's fine. Whatever. And so, and then Dana had a question of, do you really need a partner? Has it ever gone through your mind? I could have done this by myself and then the money doubles. Has that ever gone through it?
我的意思是，你们俩是出了名的好朋友。但我和斯佩德当时就想，什么？《汤姆男孩》里那个家伙和《韦恩斯世界》里那个家伙？不知道。是的。好吧，我的意思是，另外也是因为我和安吉拉在《办公室》里是“亦敌亦友”，我们的角色并不是朋友，所以当人们得知我们在现实生活中是最好的朋友时，总是感到非常惊讶。
Or maybe Angela. But that... Dana and I think about that all day, every day. People always ask us forever why. You know, why us? Why now? Are you really friends? Do you get that?
如果没有她，我根本无法完成这个播客。我这人全都是结构、秩序和电子表格。我个人版的《办公室女士》播客会非常有教育意义，但也会无趣得多。所以安吉拉带来了所有的乐趣、古怪以及所有那些奇特的观察。所以实际上，我们是一对相当不错的搭档。是的，我觉得你这么做很明智，因为人多多少少有点安全感。达纳在这方面比我强得多。
I mean, you guys are famously really close friends. But Spade and I was like, what? The Tommy Boy guy and the Wainsworth guy? I don't know. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I mean, I mean, also because Angela and I were frenemies on The Office, our characters were not friends, and people are always very surprised to learn that we are best friends in real life.
而且我觉得我自己一个人做不来。我觉得达纳真的是在强力推动，并且让我做起来更容易。不过开玩笑地说，和他开玩笑也很有趣，因为他显然是个有趣的人，我们在这方面度过了很美好的时光。而且我觉得你们拥有真正的友谊。所以人们喜欢听说你们是朋友，尽管在节目里看起来并不像。你们俩，我太喜欢你们的播客了。你们根本不知道我现在能上你们的播客有多激动。我听你们的节目。我觉得你们俩搭档太棒了。达纳，我简直不敢相信你现在在跟我说话。这简直让我脑洞大开。我是个狂热的《周六夜现场》书呆子。
I could not have done the podcast without her. I am all, like, structure and order and spreadsheets. My version of Office Ladies' podcast would be very informative, but also way less entertaining. So Angela brings all of the, like, fun. and all of the quirky and all of like the weird observations. So we're actually, we're a pretty good pair. Yeah, I think that's smart that you did that because there is kind of safety in numbers. Dana is way better at this.
在《办公室》和 NBC 工作最棒的部分就是，我能和《周六夜现场》的人呼吸同一片空气。这就好像我们必须一起出席相同的公司派对。而我完全是个追星族。这就是我 gravitate（倾向于）接近的人。简直酷毙了。但那是很久以前的事了。其实我有一段来自我在洛杉矶早期非常疯狂的故事。说来听听。和《周六夜现场》有关的。好吧，我刚到洛杉矶时是靠做打字员和速记员谋生的。你知道你得去参加那些活动吗？
And I don't think I could do myself. I think Dana really, really drives it and makes it easier to do it for me. But jokingly, it's fun to joke around with him too because he's a funny guy. obviously, and we have a good time with that. And I think you guys have a real friendship. So people like to hear that you're friends, even though it doesn't seem like it on the show. You guys, I love your podcast. Like you have no idea how excited I am to be on your podcast right now. I listen to you guys. I think you are so good together. Dana, I can't believe you're talking to me right now. That's kind of blowing my mind. I'm a huge Saturday Night Live nerd.
它们被称为电视评论家协会，你得作为演员坐在小组讨论会上，介绍新演员。这可以针对任何节目。好吧，我的工作就是去那个房间做笔记，然后回到一个酒店房间，一个挤了12个人和12台电脑的闷热酒店房间，接着听录音，把这些新闻活动的内容转录下来。哇。这些对话，是的。是的。如果我们在那天晚上按时完成工作，我们就被允许去所谓的
greatest part about being on the office and being on NBC was that I got to breathe the same air as Saturday Night Live people. This is like that we would have to be at the same corporate parties together. And I was a total groupie. That is who I gravitated toward. It was just the coolest. But that's going way back. I actually have a crazy story from my very early days in L.A. Let's hear it. And Saturday Night Live. Okay, so I made my living when I landed in L.A. as a typist and a transcriber. And you know how you'd have to go to those events.
派对，正如你们所知，那其实只是电视剧演员和那些试图获取声音素材的记者进行交流的场合。但我们可以去。我们可以吃东西，喝饮料，还能看着所有的大人物。好吧，我比什么都渴望去《周六夜现场》的派对。我渴望得甚至让我在洛杉矶那颗小小心脏都快承受不住了。所以我知道派对是哪天晚上。我前一天就开始铺垫了。我开始假装自己身体不舒服，因为我要找个借口说我生病了，这样我就可以
They're called like the Television Critics Association and you would sit on a panel as a cast and you would introduce new cast members. This would be for any show. Well, my job was to go and sit in that room and take notes and then go back to a hotel room, a hot hotel room filled with like, 12 people and 12 computers, and then listen to audio and transcribe these, like, press events. Wow. These conversations, yeah. Yes. And if we got our work done on time by that evening, we were allowed to go to the quote-unquote
按时下班，然后偷偷溜进这个派对。但我需要工时，你知道吗？所以我提前铺垫了。第二天我就装作：天哪，我还是觉得很不舒服。到了3点钟，我说，真的非常对不起。我得走了。我得回家了。那家伙说，好吧。我在车里藏了一套换洗衣服。我去了，换上了一件鸡尾酒礼服。我偷偷溜进了派对。我甚至无法形容那有多棒。诺姆·麦克唐纳。
parties, which, as you know, are really just cast members of TV shows mingling with reporters who are trying to get sound bites. But we would get to go. We'd get to eat the food, drink the drinks, and just watch all the famous people. Well, all I wanted more than anything was to go to the Saturday Night Live party. I wanted it more than my little new heart in L.A. could stand it. And so I knew what night it was coming up. And I started planting the seed the day before I started pretending like I didn't feel good because I was going to make an excuse that I was sick so that I could. get off work on time and then sneak into this party. But I needed the hours, you know? So I planted that seed. The next day I was like, man, I'm still not feeling good. At 3 o'clock, I'm like, I'm so sorry.
我正看着他。活生生的诺姆。我简直不敢相信。我的脑子炸裂了。然后我看到了莫莉·香农，心想我要上了。我要去跟莫莉·香农打招呼。我朝她走去。她当时正在给媒体提供声音采访素材。我对她说：“莫莉·香农，我是洛杉矶的一名新演员，我太崇拜你了。我只是想告诉你你对我有多重要。你知道的，你说的那些话。”“哦，当然。”她看着我，抓住我的肩膀，深深地看着我的眼睛，
I got to go. I got to go home. The guy was like, fine. I had planted a change of clothes in my car. I went, I changed into a cocktail dress. I sneak into the party. And I can't even tell you it was amazing. Norm McDonald.
说道：“不要放弃。无论如何，千万别放弃。”
I'm looking at him. in the flesh. I can't. My mind is blown. Then I see Molly Shannon and I think I'm going to do it. I'm going to go say hi to Molly Shannon. And I walk up to her. She's giving sound bites to the press. And I say, Molly Shannon, I am a new actress in L.A. and I just admire you so much. And I just wanted to tell you just what you mean to me. You know, the stuff you say. Yeah, sure. She looked at me, took me by the shoulders, looked me deep in the eyes. and said, don't give up. Whatever you do, don't give up.
我花了10年时间才登上《周六夜现场》。我给你最好的建议就是，只要你坚持下去，总有一天会实现的，好吗？哇。听起来真像我们认识的莫莉。是的，我正要说她会说些好话呢。太棒了。我去了，跟她有了这样一次偶遇，然后我一转身，我那个速记室的老板就站在那里，还有所有其他按时下班的人，他们都来到了这个派对，当时我就想：
It took me 10 years to get on Saturday Night Live. And my best advice to you is just know it'll happen eventually if you just stick with it, okay? Wow. Sounds like the Molly we know. Yeah, I was about to say she'll say something nice. Amazing. And I went and I had this encounter with her and then I turn around and my boss from the transcription room is standing. there along with everybody else who got off work on time and they came to this party and I was like
我是不是被炒了？他说：“你被炒了。”我当时想：好吧。他把我解雇了，不过没关系，伙计们，因为我遇到了莫莉·香农，她给了我那个建议。我回到家把这事告诉了我妈妈，在接下来的10年里，每当我遇到艰难的一天，我妈妈都会对我说：“珍娜，你可别忘了莫莉·香农跟你说过的话。她说别放弃。她说她花了10年才成功。你们大家拭目以待吧。”10年后，我在电影《永不止步》的首映礼上，就是我和约翰·C·赖利合作的那部电影《永不止步》——我发誓没开玩笑，你猜谁在那场派对上？莫莉·香农！莫莉·香农！还有你老板。我走过去对她说：“莫莉·香农，这是我经历的故事，10年了……”她听了就像是：“哦，你看，10年过去了，你真的来到这里了。”
am I fired and he goes you are fired. I was like okay he fired me but it was fine guys because I met Molly Shannon and she gave me that advice and I went home and I told my mom and every time I had a hard day for the next 10 years my mom would say to me Jenna don't you forget what Molly Shannon told you she said don't give up she said it took you it took her 10 years you you guys wait for it 10 years later i'm at the premiere of walk hard the movie walk hard that i did with john c riley riley i shit you not guess who's at that party molly shannon molly shannon your boss and i got to go up to her and i got to say molly shannon here's this story you told me 10 years and she was like like, oh, look, it's 10 years later, and here you are.
我还和她合了影。我让摄影师过来给我们拍了张照片。这难道不是史上最棒的事吗？莫莉知道吗，她听过这个故事吗？还是你刚……对，我那天晚上在《永不止步》的首映礼上告诉过她。哇。难以置信。
And I got a picture with her. I made the photographer come over and, like, take a picture of us. Is that the greatest thing ever? Does Molly know, has she heard this story? Or did you just? Yes, I told her that night at the Walk Hard premiere. Wow. Unbelievable.
不过现在，是的，我写了一本书，我在书里写了那个故事，书里还有一张照片。嗯。好吧，我认识大卫时他才19岁，我对他说：“你坚持住。半年内……别放弃，因为半年内——”不，大卫起步很快。如果这是短跑，他就像是：轰。达纳说：“你要搬去洛杉矶了。半年内你会得阴虱。”
But now, yes, and I wrote about, I wrote a book, and I wrote that story in the book, and I have a picture in the book, too. Mm-hmm. Well, when I met David, he was 19, I said, you hang with this. And in six months, don't give up because in six months, no, David was out of the blocks fast. If it was a sprinter, he was like, boom. Dana said, you're going to move to L.A. And in six months, you'll get crabs.
我说，好吧。《警察学校》，你好。他接了一部电影。好吧，他有过一个……我很早就接到了一部电影。21岁左右吧。那就是我拍的那部警察电影。我当时只有6000美元来买那辆被偷的车，所以我又回到了零点。
And I go, okay. Police Academy, hello. He got a movie. Well, he's had a... I got a movie early on. 21 or something. That's the police guy movie that I made. I had $6,000 to buy the car that got stolen, so I was back to zero.
哇。是的，好故事。你现在打字还是每分钟85个字吗？那可不容小觑。是的，我打。90%的准确率。关键全在准确率上。
Wow. Yeah, great story. You still type 85 words per minute. That's nothing to sneeze at. I do. I do. 90% accuracy. It's all in the accuracy.
谁都能打出一堆垃圾。你准确率有90%对吧？对，我是说，对吧？你想打出有意义的词。任何人都可以只是瞎按。我父亲是高中。真的。教什么的？
Anyone can type garbage. You're 90%, right? Yeah, I mean, right? You want to type words. Anyone can just type nothing. My father was high school. True. Teaching.
教打字的。我父亲教了几十年。你会打字吗？你们俩能用所有手指打字，还是像那种两指禅打字员？我什么都不会。如果你看到一个没受过正规培训的年轻人，比如20多岁的人，他们打字真的很快。我不知道他们是不是技术上所有手指都在用，你知道的，我们是后来才学会的，但我速度够快，不过我不用。
Typing teaching. my father for decades. Can you type, can you guys type with all your fingers or are you like two finger typeers? I can't do anything. If you see a non-taught young person like in their 20s, they're really fast. And I don't know if it's technically all using all their fingers, you know, we picked it up later, but I'm fast enough, but I don't.
珍娜，我有一个好问题，和人生的某个阶段有关。你拍《冰刀双人组》的时候，最后和威尔·法瑞尔有一场床戏，对吧？是的，没错。我和威尔有一场床戏。那是《周六夜现场》历史上最伟大的名场面之一，绝对的。那太疯狂了。而且，顺便说一句，艾米·波勒也演了那部电影。哦，对的，还有艾米。
Jenna, I have a good question that ties in the time of life. When you did Blades of Glory, you wound up getting to have sex with Will Ferrell, right? Yes, that's right. I had a sex scene with Will. That's one of the best all-time goats of S&L for sure. That was nuts. But also, by the way, Amy Poehler was in that movie. Oh, that's right, Amy.
所以她只是演我妹妹。哇塞。威尔·阿奈特也演了那部电影。是的，我的意思是，那太吓人了。那太吓人了。他在拍那场戏时非常有礼貌，因为他必须好几次抓住我的胸部。但疯狂的是，我在那场戏里穿的衣服——看起来我只穿着一件睡裙——可能比我平时穿的还要多。因为他们让你穿上塑身衣，然后是束胸衣，还有别的什么，他们还在我身上画了彩妆。
So just playing my sister. Wowie. And Will Arnett was in that movie. Yeah, I mean, that was terrifying. That was terrifying. was so polite when we shot that scene because he had to like grab my boobs like several times. But what was crazy about it was I probably had on more clothes in that scene where I look like I'm just in like a nighty than I normally wear. Like they, because they put you in like spanks and then a corset and then a thing and they painted my body with makeup.
我的意思是，我感觉自己被包裹得严严实实的。太疯狂了。他必须隔着你的衣服去抓你的胸部，但就像那种情况。你根本感觉不到，因为你身上有18层……是的，就像我穿着防弹衣一样。所以我当时有点像是：也许你抓的时候可以眨眨眼，因为我什么都感觉不到。戳戳我。
I mean, I felt like so covered. It was crazy. He has to go and grab your boobs through your stuff, but it's like that kind of thing. You can't even feel it because you've got 18 layers of... Yeah, it's like I was wearing body armor. So I was kind of like maybe like wink when you grab them because I can feel nothing. Nudge me.
这发生在 intimacy coordinators（亲密行为协调员）出现之前。当时现场没有人。只有……好吧。只有导演在说：我们来拍这个。是的。完全是这样。
This was predates intimacy coordinators. There was no one there. There was just... Okay. It was just like here's what we're doing. It was just a director going, let's do this. Yes. Exactly.
斯瓦茨也演了那部电影吗？你知道尼克·斯瓦茨也演了那个小傻瓜吗？是的。是的，他演了。天哪。我们和尼克是朋友，你知道的，这真是一场过山车般的体验，珍娜。我得这么告诉你。确实如此。我觉得他在电影里很可爱，但我知道什么呢？不，他太棒了。他太搞笑了。《放通行证》。我们甚至都还没聊到该死的《办公室》。听着，你知道的，我演过这么多作品。问题是，对于你和你的搭档来说，重新观看所有这些剧集并谈论它们。是的。
Was Swartzen in that? Do you know Nick Swartz and that? little fool. Yes. Yes, he was. Oh, my God. We are friends with Nick and, you know, it's a real rollercoaster, Jenna. I'll tell you that. It is. I found him lovely on the film, but what do I know? No, he's great. He's so funny. Hall pass. We haven't even gotten to the goddamn office. Look, you know, I've done so much stuff. What is it? The question is, is for you and your partner, re-watching all these episodes and talking about them. Yeah.
你对这部剧的看法有没有发生改变，哪怕有一点点？关于这部剧，你学到了什么，或者有什么新发现吗？因为它现在正式成为了一种文化现象，在世界各地传播，然后再次爆发。它是长青树。这是一部独特的剧集。昨天我还在看里奇·热维斯版本的《办公室》，确实如此。我的意思是，你知道的，你曾说它源自那个版本的《办公室》，但它走出了属于它自己的完全原创的道路。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，最伟大的编剧之一。所以你们俩，你们……
How is your perception, if it at all, changed about the show? What did you learn about the show or, if anything? Because it is now officially a phenomenon in the way it travels around and then explodes again. It's Evergreen. And it's a unique show. And yesterday I was watching the office with Ricky Jervais, very did. I mean, you know, you say it came from that office, but it went, it has its own complete original thing. Greg Daniels, one of the great writers. So what did you guys, what, what do you
你们对这部剧的看法有没有发生什么改变？你们从这部剧里学到了什么，如果有的话？因为它现在确实是一个现象级作品，在世界各地传播开来，然后再次爆发。它长盛不衰。而且这是一部独特的剧。昨天我看了瑞奇·热维斯出演的《办公室》，真的很棒。我的意思是，如你所知，你说它源自那部《办公室》，但它走出了自己的、完全原创的路。格雷格·丹尼尔斯是伟大的编剧之一。那么你们，你们到底
feel about that thing after doing hundreds of podcasts? Did you, did you go through every episode at some point? Yeah, every single episode, all 201 episodes. And then a lot of interviews with cast and crew. Writers? Writers, exactly. My big. Takeaway from having rewatched it was that it's really good the whole time. Because I think there was this lore, especially among the cast and the creatives, that maybe we like hit our peak in season three or season four. And also this belief that like the two seasons after Steve left, we were just treading water and maybe they weren't as good. But when I watched everything, like some of my favorite episodes were in seasons eight and nine. after Steve had left, like there were still these amazing storylines. And also, I have to say now when I look back, some of my favorite episodes were also in seasons four through six. Like, dinner party was season four. Michael Scott Paper Company, that whole arc was in season five. And that's just great TV. And, um, but yeah, I think, you know, some of the award nominations stopped after
做过几百期播客后，对那件事有什么感觉？你吗，你有没有在某个时候把每一集都看了一遍？对，每一集，全部201集。还有很多对演员和幕后人员的采访。编剧？编剧，没错。我重看之后最大的感触是，它从头到尾都真的很好。因为我觉得有一种传说，特别是在演员和主创人员当中，认为我们可能在第三季或第四季达到了巅峰。而且还有这种看法，觉得在史蒂夫离开后的那两季里，我们只是在原地踏步，可能没那么好了。但当我把所有内容都看完后，发现我最喜欢的几集居然在第八季和第九季。在史蒂夫离开之后，依然有这些精彩的故事线。而且，我必须说，现在回想起来，我最喜欢的几集也同样在第四季到第六季之间。比如，第四季的“晚宴派对”；“迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司”，整个剧情线在第五季。那真的是非常棒的电视作品。而且，嗯，不过是的，我觉得，你知道，有些奖项提名在
season three. So I think maybe we got in our heads and thought, oh, I guess we're not creating as great. I think that just happens, no matter what. Yeah, you're not the new shiny object anymore. That's a nice thing. I mean, when you're watching yourself and you're watching a thing and then you come on and stuff,
第三季之后就停了。所以我觉得我们可能有点钻牛角尖了，觉得，哦，我猜我们创作得没那么棒了。我觉得这总会发生，无论如何。对，你不再是那个光鲜亮丽的新面孔了。那倒挺好的。我的意思是，当你看着自己，看着某个作品，然后你登场之类的，
and it's something you did years ago, do you ever sometimes, because you sound like you're a normal actor, comedian that's sort of like a little self-critical, how was I? Do you ever kind of look at yourself in a scene and go, damn, I nailed that? Why did I feel insecure? care already or what's that like um i mean i have both reactions sometimes i watch it and i'm like i'll
那是你多年前做过的事情，你有时会——因为听起来你像是个普通的演员、喜剧演员，多少有点自我批判——我当时演得怎么样？你会不会看着自己在某个场景里的表现，然后说：“天哪，我演得太绝了！我为什么还要感到没安全感呢？”或者那是什么感觉？嗯，我两种反应都有。有时我看着它，心里会想：“我再也拍不出这么好的作品了，操，那太棒了。”嗯，但也有一些场景让我觉得尴尬到不行，我就想：“哦天哪，我还记得我当时是怎么跟它较劲的，怎么都演不好，现在它就摆在这里让所有人看见，我猜我只能接受并往前看了。”所以我两种反应都有。我不太清楚这其中的具体细节，但你——首先，这总是一部群戏。卡瑞尔在这个角色里有多棒，你知道，大家都知道这一点，
never do work that good again shit that was great um but then there's other scenes where i just cringe where i'm like oh god i i remember how i struggled with that and i couldn't do it and now here it is for everyone to see and i guess i just have to move on so i've had both reactions and i don't know the complete specifics of this but you it's first all it was always an ensemble how great Corell is in that part is you know everybody knows that
但它一直是一部群戏，有那么多人从这部剧里走出来，如今有了长期的职业生涯。不过我——我刚才走神了，抱歉，我脑子里浮现出了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的画面。珍娜，当你能看着它并说：
but it always was an ensemble and so many people came out of it and now have these long careers but it's I forgot my train of thoughts sorry I was seen Steve Carell in my head Jenna when you can watch it and say
“我完全进入状态了”——因为有时候你看着它，你会觉得，你就是进入了那种状态，觉得这是一场精彩的戏，这一集的整个构思都在起作用，然后他们猛地把镜头摇回来，拍到一个绝佳的表情，再猛地摇回你身上，时机完美，拍到一个绝佳的表情。当你看到的时候，你会觉得——因为你知道，你在拍摄时只能凭感觉去感受镜头，你其实并不真正知道。然后你会说：“天哪，他们太神了，砰，砰，剪辑得真好，这一切都太棒了。”这就是为什么人们真的会——呃，被它迷住。我的意思是，而且你的脸也是《办公室》极其重要的组成部分，而且超级可爱。
I was in the pocket because sometimes you watch it it and you go you're just in in the pocket of going this is a great scene this whole idea of this episode's working and they whip the camera back get a great look whip back to you perfect timing get a great look and when you see it you go because you know you can only feel the camera when you're shooting and you don't really know and then you go god they nailed that boom boom edited well everything about this is just that's why people really get uh enchanted by i mean and also just your face is so part of the office, and it's so cute.
他们总是把镜头切到你身上，你还有这些小小的支线剧情。真的，我明白为什么人们会迷上它了。无论你什么时候打开它，你都可以随便看哪一集。我想起刚才忘了说什么了，那就是——这里面有多少即兴发挥？如果有的话？因为它整体感觉非常像即兴创作，但我知道并非完全是即兴的。我知道，这是个挺酷的词，对吧？所以你们被允许说类似“大家伙儿，我能试试这个吗？”你知道的，“你们介意我做这个吗，你知道的”，诸如此类的话吗？
They always cut to you, and you have these little storylines. It's really, I see why people get hooked on it. No matter when you turn it on, you can just grab any episode. I remember what I forgot, which was how much, if any, improvisation was there? Because it comes off very improvisational in totem, but I know there wasn't completely improvised. I know, that's a pretty cool word, right? So were you allowed to kind of go, you guys, could I try this? you know, do you mind if I do, you know, that kind of stuff?
对，这真的很有协作性，而且，你知道，很多编剧同时也是剧中的演员。所以他们和我们在一起，有时候他们会直接在片场提出备选的笑话。那挺有趣的，对吧。所以这很棒。而且我们做了很多即兴发挥，但我不知道其中有多少真正被剪进正片了。我们得以玩耍并享受乐趣，但我想说，你在屏幕上看到的90%的内容都是写在剧本上的，甚至精确到他们会为我们的说话方式写出省略号，
Yeah, it was really collaborative and, you know, so many of the writers were also actors on the show. So they were with us and they would be sometimes pitching alternate jokes right there on the set. That's kind of fun, yeah. So that was neat. And we did a lot of improvising, but I don't know how much of it actually made the cut. We got to play and have fun, but I would say like 90% of what you see. on the screen was written on the page down to like they would write in ellipses for our speech
这样你就知道要稍微停顿一下，因为他们知道他们会在那个停顿期间猛甩镜头，这样他们就能转回拍你。所以这里面有着非常精细的编排，就是把镜头稍微甩得慢一点点，让它看起来——而且你得留出气口，对吧——让它看起来好像他们没完全对准节奏。是的，完全正确。所以很多时候当我们进行排练时，他们会说：“珍娜，能在你下一句台词前留个气口吗，这样我们就有时间做那个甩镜头了？”所以这就意味着我们会加上一些诸如“嗯”之类的话。他们会找到你。
like so you knew to kind of pause because they knew they were going to whip the camera during that pause and so they could get back to you so there was a very elaborate choreography of whipping the camera a little too late so that it seemed and you'd have to get handles yeah so it seemed like they didn't quite do it right yeah yes exactly and so So a lot of times when we would do a rehearsal, they would say, Jenna, will you give a handle before your next line so we have time for that camera whip? So that would be we would add things like, well. They'd find you.
这样他们就能找到你，比如在准确的时机。但这也显得非常真实。许多非语言的表演，以及那些切给一个没有台词、只是非语言地做出某种姿态的角色的镜头。它，它立刻就让人觉得如此新颖。我不用“新鲜”这个词，大卫以前经常用这个词，但立刻，我想对于喜剧演员来说，看着它也会觉得，这看起来很酷，这看起来很有趣，这看起来与众不同而且真的很好笑。它一点也不强求。你知道，就是那种——嗯，我们有两个肩扛摄像机的摄像师，而这两个人都是
So that they could find you, like in the right timing. But it also seems very real. A lot of the nonverbal acting and those cutaways to a character that isn't saying a line, but just sort of nonverbally doing some kind of attitudes. stuff. It, it was immediately just felt so new. I'm not going to say fresh. David would use that word a lot, but immediately, I think for comedians as well, watching it going, this looks cool, this looks fun, this looks different and really funny. It doesn't push at all. You know, it's the Well, we had two camera operators with cameras on their shoulders, and both of these guys were
来自《幸存者》。所以这些人曾带着《幸存者》的人一起走过不管什么地方，荒野，去捕捉《幸存者》的画面。这就是他们纪录片背景的来源。A机摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩，他也是我们的摄影指导，后来成为了一名导演，现在，你知道的，是《小学的 Abbott》等节目的执行制片人。兰德尔是我们的A机摄影师，他的工作是拍下所有的对话，
from survivor. So these guys had like walked through the whatever, the wilderness with the survivor people capturing survivor. So this is where they came from in the documentary world. And camera A, Randall Einhorn, who was also our cinematographer who went on to be a director and is now, you know, the executive producer of Abbott Elementary and all those things. Randall was our A camera and his job was to get all of the dialogue. and then Matt Sown he was our B camera and then his job was to get
然后马特·索恩是我们的B机摄影师，他的工作就是拍下——所有你刚才提到的那些东西，达娜，所有在背景中发生的表演。所以每当一个场景发生时，我们全天都在彼此场景的背景中，在片场整整待满12个小时，
all of those things you're talking about Dana all of the acting that was happening in the background so whenever a scene was happening we were all in the background of each other's scenes all day long on set the full 12 hours
史蒂夫·卡瑞尔也不例外。我无法告诉你史蒂夫·卡瑞尔有多少次不得不坐在迈克尔·斯科特的办公室里，仅仅为了出现在吉姆和帕姆互相对视的背景里，因为我们要捕捉他们的一部分画面，对吧，因为我们要看一部分。我们要看你的一部分。这就像我们可以印在马克杯上的东西。
Steve Corell included I can't tell you how many times Steve Carell had to sit in Michael Scott's office just to be in the background of Jim and Pam looking at each other because we get a piece of them yeah because we're going to to see a piece. We're going to see a piece of you. It's like something we could put on a mug.
那其实会是个很棒的剧组礼物。对。所以他会抓住并推近拍摄所有——你知道的，任何在场景背景中的人，实时捕捉他们的反应。这是一种非常酷的工作方式。对。不过你得保持状态。确实。每一场戏。但它能保持你的活力。对。你知道的，因为对我来说，拍电影最难的事情在于，在实际表演之间有很长的空闲时间。感觉就像，哦天哪，我得重新进入状态。对，而且，你知道的，我不知道这样说对不对。但如果你觉得你当时正在发现一些新鲜的东西，那真的很棒。
That'd actually be a great cast gift. Yeah. And so he would grab and push in on all of the, you know, anyone who was in the background of a scene and get their reactions in real time. It was such a cool way to work. Yeah. And you have to stay alive though. You do. Every scene. But it keeps your energy up. Yeah. You know, because that's the hardest thing for me about acting in movies is like, They had long amounts of downtime between when you're actually acting. It's just like, oh, God, I got to ramp up again. Yeah, and it's just, you know, I don't know if this is the correct way to say it. But if you feel like if you're discovering something new in the moment, it's really nice.
这确实能让你的大脑保持活跃。而在传统电影中，我以前做的那种，你知道的，你在早上七八点左右拍三个主镜头，然后到了五六点钟，你开始拍……哦，不是吗，八个小时前拍那个主镜头时，你的左胳膊是抬着的，你在这一点上打开了车门。这与你们所经历的完全相反，至少给人的感觉是这样的，它很有活力，感觉很真实，你知道吗？确实如此，而且我们没有定位标，你知道的，对于外行来说，
It does keep your brain alive. And in traditional movies, what I was doing, you know, you do the three masters at seven or eight a.m. or whatever. And then by five or six o'clock, you start. and, oh, don't you, and the master eight hours ago, your left elbow was up and you open the car door at this point. It's the antithesis of what you guys had, at least the way it felt, it popped, it felt real, you know? For sure, and we did not have marks, you know, those that for people out there,
就像你在地上贴上胶带，然后你必须站在上面，因为那样才能保证对焦。但我们没有定位标。如果收音话筒杆伸进了镜头里，我们就让它留在里面，因为，你知道的，在这个世界里这是行得通的。当我拍完——当我，你知道的，回到《荣誉之刃》，《荣誉之刃》是我在被《办公室》选中后拍的第一部大电影。我反复地盯着摄像机的镜头看。
like you put tape on the ground and then you have to stand on it because that's how you're going to be in focus. But we had no marks. And if the boom dipped in shot, we just kept it in because, you know, It worked in the world. And when I finished, when I, you know, going back to Blades of Glory, Blades of Glory was the first big movie I did after being cast on the office. And I repeatedly kept looking down the barrel of the camera.
就像我和威尔还有艾米拍一场戏，然后我会朝镜头看一眼。我会想：“操，我不能这么做。”而且我突然得去找定位标了。我太僵硬了。这真的很有压力，因为我一直呆在另一个世界里。你可以看到有时候电影里的演员
Like I would do a scene with Will and Amy. And then I would like give a look to camera. I'd be like, fuck, I can't do that. And also I suddenly had to hit a mark. And I was so stiff. It was really stressful because I'd been in this other. world. You can watch when people on movies sometimes
你有没有看过有人走路时往下看，寻找他们的定位标，然后抬起头。我太喜欢了。这太可怕了。我还想说——我本想说这部剧很“新鲜”，但有趣的是，“新鲜”这个词已经烂大街了。不过我要把它重新捡起来。
have you ever watched someone looks down when they walk and look for their mark and then they look up. I love it. It's so horrifying. I want to say also, I was going to say this show is fresh, but it's funny that the term fresh is stale. But also I'm going to bring it back.
《办公室》曾经很新鲜，而Peacock上那部叫《The Paper》的新剧。你看过吗？你对它了解多少？好吧。我没看过，但我有机会去了片场。安吉拉和我获得了特许进入片场，并和所有演员聊了聊。我们看到了它。真的很酷，但我们什么都不能说。哦，是的。我想它已经制作完成了。就像他们拍完了。它九月份上映。哦，有意思。
The office was fresh and the new one called the paper on Peacock. Have you seen that? Do you know much about it? Okay. I haven't seen it, but I got to go to the set. Angela and I got special access to the set and got to talk to all the actors. We got to see it. It's really cool, but we're not allowed to say anything. Oh, yeah. I think it's in the can. Like they finished it. It comes out in September. Oh, interesting.
哦，九月在哪个平台？Peacock。Peacock，对吧？所以有了约翰·卡拉辛斯基，就像吉姆和帕姆的故事线变成了一件大事。我跟一些20出头的人聊过，有一天我告诉他们我要采访你和《办公室》。他们说——我说，她就是帕姆。
Oh, September on where? Peacock. Peacock, right? So with John Cresents, like the Jim and Pam narrative became such a big thing. I talked to some people in the early 20s a day told him I was going to review you and on the office. They go, I go, she was Pam.
哦，帕姆，你知道吗？这就像是一个著名的角色。还有吉姆和帕姆。我只是有点好奇，因为约翰·卡拉辛斯基，我觉得他拍出那部恐怖片的经历真的非常、非常有趣。那部《寂静》，叫什么来着？
Oh, Pam, you know? This is like a famous character. And Jim and Pam. I'm just kind of curious because John Krasinski, I find it really, really interesting how he came up with that horror film. The Quiet, what was it?
《寂静》。《寂静之地》。《寂静之地》。有趣的是，当演员们突然之间让你看到，他们心想：哇，这家伙真的很会导演。你在他身上看到过这方面的苗头吗，在智力上或者只是他平日里的为人处世？当他开始执导时，你感到意外吗？对我们所有人来说都不意外。
The Quiet. A quiet place. Quiet place. And it's interesting when actors just all of a sudden you see them, they're like, wow, this guy can really direct. And did you see any seeds of that in him intellectually or just the way he was around? Was that a surprise to you when he came out directing? It was a surprise to none of us.
哦，我倒不觉得。约翰，我总是对约翰说，我觉得你会成为我们的汤姆·汉克斯。就像，还记得汤姆·汉克斯演的《亲密伙伴》吗？那是一部非常著名、非常成功的电视剧。但当你想到汤姆·汉克斯时，你不会想到《亲密伙伴》。你会想到汤姆·汉克斯拍过的所有其他作品。当时我就觉得，《办公室》会成为你的《亲密伙伴》——你的前途无量。
Oh, I didn't think so. John, I would always say to John, I think you're going to be like our Tom Hanks. Like, remember how Tom Hanks did bosom buddies? And he was like a very famous successful TV show. But like when you think of Tom Hanks, you don't think of bosom buddies. You think of everything else Tom Hanks has done. And I was like, I think the office is going to be your bosom buddies. Like you're going places.
这非常明显。那他有没有看着地面说：“哦，天哪，珍娜？”或者他是怎么反应的？他是，是的，他在这方面非常谦虚，你知道的。就像那样，如果我对他说这话，他会觉得很尴尬，你知道的，他不想被人那样大惊小怪地捧着。但我当时就说：“不，是真的，先生。”好吧，导演一部电影简直是一项海格力斯式的任务。
It's very clear. And did he look down at the ground and go, oh, shucks, Jenna? Or how did he did? He's very, yes, he's very humble in that way, you know. Like that would be, if I say that to him, that's very embarrassing. to him, you know, like, he doesn't want to be, like, fussed over like that. But I was like, no, it's true, Mr. Well, it's a Herclian task to direct a movie.
我是说，无论是体力上还是精神上。但达娜总是对我大惊小怪的。大惊小怪？对。你会对大惊小怪。我想听听更多关于你以前当电话灵媒的事。对。那是。
I mean, just physically and mentally. But Dana fusses over me all the time. Fusses? Yeah. You fuss over me. I want to hear more about you being a telephone psychic when you got. Yeah. That was.
她在洗车场工作过。我确实在洗车场干了三个夏天，那是我最好的工作。我在隆琼·西尔弗斯（Long John Silver's）干过。那是我的第一份工作。我在一家冰淇淋店卖过冰淇淋。然后我在洗车场找到了工作。所有这些都在圣路易斯郊区一条叫曼彻斯特路的路上。我被隆琼·西尔弗斯开除了。我被冰淇淋店开除了。我爸爸会说：“哦，我猜你这是要把曼彻斯特路上的每一家店都给炒一遍鱿鱼吧。”但洗车场的工作留下来了。那真的很棒。工资很高。我就在外面，负责把车擦干，你知道的。那个圈子里的
She worked as a car wash. I did work at a car for three summers, and that was my best. job. I worked at Long John Silvers. That was my first job. I worked at an ice creamery serving ice cream. And then I got the job at the car wash. All of those were on this road called Manchester Road in St. Louis out in the suburbs. And I got fired from Long John Silver's. I got fired from the ice creamery. And my dad would say, oh, you're just looking to get fired from every business on Manchester Road, I guess. But the car wash stuck. And that was great. They was great money. I was outside, just drying off the cars, you know. How big are tips in that
小费有多少？因为我尽量想给好小费，但是……好吧。这就像，就像在那个时候。嗯，顺便说一句，他们总是让我把车钥匙还给那些男士。哦，钥匙。对。对。对。你得站在车旁挥手。哦，对。你知道的，穿着你的小短裤和剪裁短袖衬衫，然后说：“您的车准备好了。”嗯，我跟你们讲。对不起。我，我不是，你知道的，不是在吹牛，但我有时能拿到五块钱小费。不错。五块大洋。嗯哼。
world? Because I try to tip well, but. Okay. This is like, like back then. Well, and by the way, they would always make me give the gentleman back their cars. Oh, the keys. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You got to stand at the car and wave. Yeah. Oh, yeah. You know, and your little shorts and your little cutoff shirt and like your car's ready. Um, and I'm talking well. I'm sorry. I would, I'm not, you know, not to brag, but I would get a five sometimes. Nice. Fiverr. Mm-hmm.
但我得把它放进类似集体小费箱的东西里。哦，不。小费集中分配？小费集中分配。对。你在你的——我是说，有几张还是进了我的口袋。我不会撒谎的。
But then I had to put it in like the group bucket. Oh, no. Pooling tips? Pooling tips. Yeah. You're in your. I mean, a few of them made it into my pocket. I'm not going to lie.
那么，你到底有百分之多少真的是个灵媒？你觉得自己有一点点吗？我想说百分之零。但你相信灵媒的潜力吗？还是你觉得这完全就是……他们让我感到毛骨悚然。我不希望一个灵媒告诉我未来会发生什么。我喜欢相信自己拥有自由意志，你知道吗？
Now, how, what percentage of you is really a psychic? Do you think some of you? I would say zero percent. But do you believe in the potentiality of psychics at all? Or do you think it's all just... They creep me out. Like, I don't want a psychic to tell me what's going to happen to me. I like to believe I have free will, you know?
我不想经历那种事。那只会给我带来噩梦。我只看过一次灵媒，那至今还萦绕在我心头。对。这会改变你的行为。他们一告诉你什么，你就会做出不同的决定。这就是我的感受。比如，你会经历这个那个。
I don't want to have that. That just will give me nightmares. I saw one psychic one time and it still haunts me. Yeah. It will change what you'll do. The second they tell you something, you'll make a different decision. That's what I feel. Like, you will do this and this.
他们会说，好吧，他们会说，哦，随便举个例子。你将在未来10年内结婚。所以你遇到了某个人，也许你会给他一个你以前不会给的机会。你会想，我想这就是我要嫁的那个男人。完全正确。这很诡异。每一个小细节都稍微改变了一点，所以你无法真正得到原本那个领域的相同结果。我在上大学时去看过一个灵媒，我问她的核心问题是：我会嫁给我暗恋的这个家伙吗？
They go, okay, as they'll say, oh, random example. You'll get married with the next 10 years. So you meet someone and maybe you give him a different chance than you would before. You're like, I think this is the guy I'm going to marry. That's exactly right. It's weird. Every little thing changed a little bit so you can't really get the same outcome of the field. I went to a psychic in college and my big question for her was, am I going to marry this guy I have a crush on?
他们会说，好吧，就像他们会说的，噢，一个随便的例子。你会在接下来的10年里结婚。所以你遇到了某人，也许你会给他一个与以往不同的机会。你会想，我觉得这就是我要嫁的那个人。完全正确。这很奇怪。每一个小细节都改变了一点点，所以你无法真正从这个领域得到相同的成果。我上大学时去过一个算命先生那里，我问她的主要问题是，我会嫁给这个我暗恋的家伙吗？
I was obsessed with him. I'm going to marry him. She said, no, you're not. You're not going to marry him. She said, but you're going to be famous one day. I said, I am. I want to be an actress. I'm going to be famous.
我曾为他着迷。我要嫁给他。她说，不，你不会的。你不会嫁给他。她说，但你总有一天会成名。我说，我会的。我想成为一名演员。我要成名。
She said, you're not going to be famous for acting. You're going to be famous in the world of religion. Hmm. Yeah, she said I was going to be a famous religious leader. She had it with acting. She should have stuck with that. Here's a review. Here's a review that I brought.
她说，你不会因为演戏而出名。你会在宗教界出名。嗯。是的，她说我要成为一个著名的宗教领袖。她对演戏已经无语了。她本该坚持演戏的。这里有一篇评论。这是我带来的一篇评论。
Office ladies is a religious experience. This was from the St. Louis Dispatcher. No, I've made that. Dispatch. Dispatch. If you want to have fun You have a play, by the way You've done plays
《办公室女孩》是一次宗教体验。这是来自《圣路易斯快报》。不，我编的。快报。快报。如果你想找点乐子，顺便说一句，你演过戏，你演过戏
It looks like from your prep here You've done plays But you have another one coming up Ashland Avenue Ashland Avenue World premiere At the Goodman Theater in Chicago Yeah, I'm heading out there
从你这里的准备工作来看，你演过戏。但你还有另一部作品即将上演：《阿什兰大道》。《阿什兰大道》世界首演，在芝加哥古德曼剧院。是的，我要去那里。
In August for rehearsals And then the play opens in September Tickets going to sale in June on 27th Now doing a play Dave and I were just talking about this for you came on Doing a play Is it more exciting or is it just something?
八月份去排练，然后九月份戏剧开演。门票六月二十七日开售。演话剧——戴夫和我刚刚在你来之前还在讨论这个——演话剧，是更让人兴奋，还是只是某种……
I couldn't even imagine you wrapping my head around the full script that you have to memorize. Does that take days, weeks? Are you good at that? It takes weeks. I think I'm okay at it. Plays are my favorite thing. I was a theater major. There's no money in doing theater.
我甚至无法想象自己能把你要背的完整剧本烂熟于心。这需要几天、几周的时间？你擅长这个吗？这需要几周时间。我觉得我在这方面还行。话剧是我的最爱。我大学主修戏剧。演戏剧赚不到钱。
But it's where my heart is. And what I love is that you get to tell the whole story and go on the characters complete journey every night. You don't have to like prepare it and then you shoot it out of order. And I also just love that it like, it lives and breathes with the audience. And each play can only be seen one time. Like each performance is slightly different. And you have it. And then just like only the people who were there got to see it. It just is like really magical to me. And I love it. It's all I want to do moving forward. I want to just be a theater actress.
但这是我的心之所向。我最喜欢的是，你可以讲述完整的故事，每天晚上都经历角色的完整旅程。你不需要先排练好，然后按顺序之外的方式去拍摄。我也很喜欢它那种与观众同呼吸共命运的感觉。而且每部剧只能看一次。比如每场演出都略有不同。而你拥有它。然后就像只有当时在场的人才能看到一样。这对我来说真的很神奇。我太爱了。这就是我以后想做的一切。我只想当一名话剧演员。
It's interesting. I've gotten more into plays the last 10 years just in London. I'm not an intellectual in New York and stuff. And it's interesting, the curtain call. And then they stand and there's a standing ovation. And then you can tell by their body language how they felt, especially when they're walking off. Like sometimes they're slumping and sometimes you see someone literally twirl around almost. Like we've or high fiving.
这很有趣。过去十年里，我更多地接触了戏剧，主要是在伦敦。我在纽约可不是什么知识分子。很有趣，谢幕的时候。然后他们起立，全场起立鼓掌。从他们的肢体语言中，你能看出他们的感受，特别是当他们离场的时候。有时候他们垂头丧气，有时候你会看到有人 literalmente（字面意思上）转圈圈，甚至击掌。
We nailed it. You know that you saw one that. had that chemistry. Like you said, they're not always at that level. That's why you have. Right. They're like fingerprints. Dana, I think you'll agree stand up is, you know, I go on the road, going mostly to places Jenna lived. But when I go on the road, you do a show and everyone goes, oh, I saw your show, I saw your show. But you remember that city and you go, oh, that one went pretty well. Even though it's just microscopically different. Yeah. But you know, sometimes you get off and you go, I could not get going perfectly. And sometimes you're like, from the second I went out,
我们做到了。你知道你看过一场有这种化学反应的演出。正如你所说，它们并不总是在那个水平。这就是为什么你有。没错。它们就像指纹一样。达纳，我想你会同意，单口喜剧，你知道的，我到处巡演，主要去珍娜住过的地方。但当我巡演时，你做完一场演出，每个人都说，哦，我看了你的演出，我看了你的演出。但你会记住那个城市，然后想，哦，那场演出的效果挺好。尽管它只有极其微小的差别。是的。但你知道，有时你下台后会想，我状态怎么就调整不好呢。有时你会觉得，从我走上台的那一秒起，
it was perfect. I said everything right. I had the right attitude. And so plays are like that where whoever comes is going to see that night's experience and it will be a hair difference. The audience is the partner in many ways? Is it, is it a drama? They steer it. It is a comedy, but it will also break your heart into a million pieces. So what it's about is it's about a guy who owns an old like TV shop in Chicago on Ashland Avenue. And he's a guy who used to have a dozen TV shops in Chicago. But, you know, mom and pop shops have gone away for the big box, you know, places. And so, and so he's being honored by the city of Chicago for being a small business owner. I play his daughter. And basically, it's a play about this man dealing with being in his 70s and basically life is kind of telling him, we don't, we don't really need what you have to offer anymore. He's like dealing with his own relevancy. Like the thing that he's good at is owning this TV shop and selling people TVs. But it's like, you know what? We don't need that anymore.
一切都太完美了。我说的一切都对。我的态度很端正。所以话剧也是这样，无论是谁来，都会看到当晚的体验，它会有极其微小的差别。在很多方面，观众都是合作伙伴？它是一部正剧吗？他们在掌控它。它是一部喜剧，但它也会把你的心撕成碎片。所以它的内容是这样的：讲的是一个在芝加哥阿什兰大道上拥有一家老式电视修理店的家伙。他曾经在芝加哥拥有十几家电视修理店。但是，你知道，夫妻老婆店已经败给了大型仓储卖场。因此，芝加哥市要表彰他作为小企业主的贡献。我扮演他的女儿。基本上，这是一部关于这个男人面对自己七十多岁时的生活，以及生活在某种程度上告诉他——我们不再真正需要你所能提供的东西了。他在处理自己的不相干感。他擅长的东西就是拥有这家电视修理店，向人们出售电视机。但这就好像是，你知道吗？我们不再需要那个了。
And so what do you do with that when the world is kind of done with your skill? And so it's kind of heartbreaking, but it's also a comedy. And then as his daughter, who has grown up, just being in this TV shop as well, and it looks like it's going away, like I have to decide, well, I'm kind of getting a chance here to do something else with my life and strike out on my own. And what does that mean to me? Do you feel like they, the audience is, obviously, they're familiar who you are from the office. And then they want to come see you. And so. So how different is this character compared to Pam? This character is different from Pam, for sure.
那么当世界某种程度上不再需要你的技能时，你该怎么办？所以这有点让人心碎，但它也是一部喜剧。然后作为他的女儿，从小也是在这家电视修理店里长大，眼看着它就要消失了，我必须做出决定，好吧，我在这里得到一个机会，可以用我的生活去做别的事情，开始我自己的闯荡。这对意味着什么？你觉得他们——观众——很明显，他们因为《办公室》而熟悉你。然后他们想来看你演出。所以。那么这个角色和帕姆比起来有多大不同？这个角色和帕姆绝对是不一样的。
And that's something like, you know, that's my whole career since Pam, is that most people just want to see more Pam. It doesn't totally bother me. But I think I'm going to be, I think you'll be able to go on this journey even, you know, I think it'll be okay. I would say, you know, because I, an audience, I'm doing standout, they do want to see characters that I did on SNL and I just totally, of course, I'll do them. They're my hits. The only thing worse than not than having hits or a hit show is not having a hit show. So it's just. There it is. That's right. Yeah. So it's a good problem to have. And I think that from reading your prep, guest prep, you know, you've just done a lot of stuff since the office. So it certainly was a star. starting point for you. Do you still just love it? Do you just love performing? Like you? I do. I do. You know, I think I'm a mom now. I have two kids. And one of the things that was really hard, though, was just the amount of focus and frankly, like, self-involvement that is necessary to be an actor or a performance artist or you know but it's true like like you you you don't want to go all the way into
这就是那种……你知道的，这就是我演完帕姆之后的整个职业生涯，大多数人只是想看到更多的帕姆。这并不完全困扰我。但我认为我会……我想你也会能够融入这段旅程，即使……你知道，我觉得会没问题的。我会说，你知道的，因为我，作为一个做单口喜剧的演员，他们确实想看我在《周六夜现场》（SNL）里塑造的角色，而我完全——当然，我会演。那是我的成名作。比没有成名作或没有热门节目更糟糕的事情，就是没有热门节目。所以它只是。就是这样。没错。是的。所以这是一个甜蜜的烦恼。而且我觉得从阅读你的采访准备资料来看，你知道的，自从《办公室》之后，你确实做了很多事情。所以它当然是一个起点。你现在还喜欢它吗？你只是喜欢表演吗？就像你一样？我喜欢。我喜欢。你知道，我想我现在是个妈妈了。我有两个孩子。不过，真正困难的事情之一，就是成为一名演员、表演艺术家所必须的专注度，坦白说，还有那种自我沉溺。你知道，但这是真的，就像你——你不想彻底陷入
narcissism because that's a real bummer but there is a there is a type of selfishness and self-involvement that is necessary for being an artist because that's how you create that's how you get in the space to create and um but that is that lane is not compatible with the kind of parent i want to be um i want to be a you know a kid focused kid-centered type of parent. And so I have changed the things I've said yes to or the things I do acting wise since I had kids, mostly so that they were kind of like more softballs, you know, like things I could do without getting too dark or self-involved or selfish, things that I could completely leave at work. I wasn't bringing anything home with me that was going to like bleed
自恋，因为那真的很扫兴，但作为一名艺术家，确实需要某种程度的自私和自我沉溺，因为那是你创作的方式，那是你进入创作空间的方式，而且，但是这种生活方式与我想成为的那种父母并不相容，我只想做一个以孩子为中心、以孩子为重点的父母。所以自从有了孩子之后，我改变了那些我答应的事情，或者我在表演方面做的事情，主要是为了让它们变得更轻松一些，你知道的，就像我可以做的事情，而不会变得太黑暗、太自我沉溺或太自私，我可以把这些事情完全留在工作岗位上。我没有把任何会渗透到
into their lives. Oldest time. Oldest show business. All this. All this show business. All all those kind of conflicts. And one thing that occurred to me recently, why it's sort of emotional or personal, like I have a lot of good friends who maybe real estate agents or different type of jobs. But we are our product,
他们生活中的东西带回家。老一套了。老掉牙的演艺圈。所有这一切。所有这些演艺圈的冲突。最近我突然意识到一件事，为什么它感觉有点情绪化或个人化，比如我有很多好朋友可能是房地产经纪人或其他类型的工作。但我们自己就是产品，
our physicality, our voice, who we are. And so it's a personal thing. You're out there doing the play. And if it's not going well, you didn't feel like I had enough time to prep. It's just personal. So I think it is really common and difficult to balance the emotion
我们的身体、我们的声音、我们是谁。所以这是一件很私人的事情。你在外面演话剧。如果演得不顺，你会觉得我没有足够的准备时间。这太私人了。所以我认为，在平衡家庭的情感与表演者和艺术家的个人化体验方面，这真的很普遍也很困难，这就好像……当孩子降临，突然之间这就是他们的世界，你甚至无法抗拒，它就那样消失了，你会想，现在我的激光般聚焦于此，我不能像以前那样了，你知道，这完全正确，那是你人生中改变的一部分，演艺界有些人——我觉得碧昂丝让她的女儿和她一起巡演，女儿大概12岁——有些人就是会过那种生活，但谁比我更有钱呢。这和给你的孩子一种稳定、老式的生活方式是不同的。
with the family versus just how personal it is as a performer and artist it's like and when kids come along you're just now suddenly it's their world and you're you can't even help it it just goes away you're like now I'm lasered on this and I can't be like I was you know that's exactly right that's like in part of your life where it changes there are some people in showman I think Beyonce has her daughter touring with her who's like 12 there are some people just take do that kind of lifestyle but who's richer than me. That's different than giving your kids kind of a stable, old-fashioned lifestyle.
好吧，我记得我早期和一个家庭治疗师谈过，因为我喜欢做心理治疗，我当时在谈论想要孩子，并试图弄清楚，我该如何将这一点与演员的身份平衡起来？她说了句让我印象深刻的话。她说，嗯，基本上有两种类型的家庭。你可以有以父母为中心的家庭，或者以孩子为中心的家庭。她说，无论你想选择哪一种，都没有对错之分。但在一个以父母为中心的家庭里，如果你有事业，你的孩子就会围绕着你
Well, I remember I talked to a family therapist, like, early on because I like therapy, and I was talking about wanting to have kids and trying to figure out, how am I going to balance that with, you know, being an actor? And she said something that really stuck with me. She said, well, there's kind of two types of families. You can have parent-centered homes or child-centered homes. And she's like, and there's no judgment, which one you want to pick. But in a parent-centered home, if you have a career, your children will orbit around you
和你的事业转。如果你去拍电影，你把他们带上，你给他们请家教。他们基本上只是融入了你的生活。她说，但在一个以孩子为中心的家庭里，你知道，你会以孩子为中心。如果你需要去做一个项目，她说，想象一下你的家庭就像一条流淌的河。你不是把整条河改道流向电影，而是自己分流出一条小溪。你拍完电影，然后重新汇入河流。但目标是让这条河继续做它该做的事。
in your career. And if you go to a movie, you bring them with you and you have tutors. And they sort of like just go into your life. She's like, but in a child-centered home, you know, you center it around the children. And if you need to go do a project, she was like, imagine like your family is flowing like a river. And rather than diverting the whole river to the movie, you just, you take a little stream by yourself. You do the movie and then you rejoin the river later. But the goal is to keep the river doing its thing.
我真的很喜欢这个比喻。我想，是的，我想选那一种。你能——我不知道你想不想公开说——我能要那个治疗师的电话号码吗？或者？我想你已经给了我们很棒的要点。这是一个相当不错的……你管这叫什么？一个类比，一个隐喻。我不知道。
And I really liked that. And I thought, yeah, I want to do that one. Could you, I don't know if you want to do it publicly, but could I get the number of that therapist or? I think you gave us solid bullet points. That's a pretty good little. What do you call that? an analogy, a metaphor. I don't know.
这就是其中之一。这太棒了。太棒了。她还说，你知道的，有一件困难的事是，她说当你——她说当你选择和你生孩子的那个人时，她说，你会想找一个观点一致的人，因为没有什么比一个父母想要以父母为中心的家庭，而另一个父母想要以儿童为中心的家庭更糟糕的了。然后她还说，在以父母为中心的家庭中长大的孩子，很难创造以孩子为中心的家庭，因为他们会想：嘿，等一下，我现在是成年人了。轮到我了。
It's one of those things. It was great. It was great. She also said like, you know, something that's hard, though, is she said when you, she said when you pick the person you want to have kids with, she's like, you're going to want a person who agrees with you because there's nothing worse than one parent who wants a parent-centered home and another parent who wants a child parent, you know, a child-centered home. And then she also said people who have grown up in parent-centered home. have a very hard time creating kid-centered homes because they're like, hey, wait a second, I'm the adult now. It's my turn.
是的。所以这是对的，对吧？就像你小时候，生活是围绕着你的父母旋转的。然后如果现在要围绕着你的孩子旋转，你就会想：那我什么时候能有高光时刻？是的。我觉得，这太值得细细琢磨了，对吧？是的。嗯，60年代太不一样了，你知道的。
Yeah. So it's right, right? Like you grew up, like revolving around your parent. And then if you revolve around your kid, you're like, when was my shot? Yeah. I thought it was, it was just so much to chew on, right? Yeah. Well, the 60s was so different, you know.
我想那时候是以父母为中心的。是的，你当时要独立得多。比如我五岁的时候就走路去上学，你知道的，当时也没有戴头盔。你知道的，肯定的。所以现在它变得非常以孩子为中心了。过去是“儿童应当被看见而不应被听见”。现在则是“当我们看电视时，大人应该闭上嘴”。达纳，不过你现在去邮箱拿信时都会戴着头盔。
I guess it was a parent-centric. It was, you just were so much more independent. Like I was walking to school at age five, you know, and there were no helmets. You know, you know, for sure. And so it's become very child-centric, you know. It used to be children should be seen but not heard. And now it's adults should keep their mouths shut when we're watching, you know. And Dana, you wear a helmet now, though, when you go to the mailbox.
但那是他自己的选择。那是我的选择。这是一种时尚选择。珍娜，在你离开之前还有两件事。不过第一件，我觉得当你演话剧时，我演单口巡演时也会这么想。当你演话剧时，我想让我害怕的是你必须每天都感觉良好。就像你必须去那里并做好心理准备。听起来很傻，但在那两个小时左右的时间里，你要站着、坐着、经历这一切，保持完全的警觉。
But that's his own choice. That's my own choice. It's a fashion choice. Jenna, two more things before we let you go. But one, I thought when you do a play, I think of this when I do stand up on the road. When you do a play, I think what would scare me is you have to feel good every day. Like you have to go there and prep yourself. It sounds stupid, but to stand, to sit, to go through, to be fully alert for those two hours or whatever.
这其实是一件很难的事。这甚至会在你脑海中闪过吗，还是你总是保持积极的心态去面对？不，我是说，我有一堆仪式和迷信的做法。哦，真的吗，你也有？对，你们呢？我有声乐热身。我有身体热身。我有一顿喜欢吃的饭，因为我知道它不会让我感觉太饱或太饿。或者生病之类的。对。对。就像，不，我绝对不会尝试任何新食物。是的，是的。你有这个吗？对。我是说，我和达纳上周还在聊，比如在我们上台之前，我偶尔会有眼睫毛掉进眼睛里。上周又发生了，
That's kind of a hard thing. Does it ever even cross your mind or you're always just kind of positive? to it. No, I mean, I have a bunch of like rituals and superstitions that I do. Oh, yeah, you do? Yeah, do you guys? I have like, I have like a vocal warm up. I have like a body warm up. I have a meal that I like to eat because I know that it's not going to make me feel too full or too hungry. Or sick or anything. Yeah. Yeah. Like, no, I'm definitely not experimenting with any kind of new food. Yep, yep. Do you have that? Yeah. I mean, Dana and I were just talking last week, like before we went on stage, I get an eyelash in my eye once in a while. It happened last week again,
达纳。就在你走上台之前，任何事情都可能发生，你会觉得：我不能去洗手间，我不能吃东西，我什么也做不了。在接下来的整整一个小时里，我必须感觉良好。不能有任何分心。这真的很奇怪，因为在平时的生活中，你总是可以戳手机，你可以看这个，你可以去休息，而现在你却要这样。话剧还要演得更久。仅仅是觉得肚子有点咕咕叫或者背痛什么的，你就会想：哦该死，我能行吗？我要找人替补吗？你知道，太奇怪了。我左腿有一阵刺痛，大概在左腿内部。所以突然之间，我的左腿动不了了。
Dana. And anything can happen right before you walk out and you're like, I can't pee, I can't eat, I can't do anything. I have to feel good for the next hour straight. There can be no distractions. And it's very weird because your life, you can always poke at your phone, you can look at this, you can go rest through, and you go this. And it plays even longer. And just to feel like you had a grumbly stomach or your back hurts or something, you're like, oh shit, can I do this? Do I call in somebody? You know, so weird. I had a shooting pain in my left leg, kind of inside my left leg. And so all of a sudden, my left leg was inoperable.
当时我在两千人面前表演。我陷入了一种……我想，好吧，只能硬着头皮上了，把它融入到表演中去，你知道的。然后它自己就好了。我还感兴趣的是，除了我们都会这样做，而且我觉得这很棒——你有特定的演出日准备。但是扮演你父亲的那位绅士，他叫什么名字？弗兰·盖南（Fran Geinen）。所以拉里·戴维刚才在谈论他通常在做任何事情时。
I was playing in front of 2,000 people. And I was in a, and I'm like, okay, got to go with this, you know, incorporated into the act, you know. And then it worked itself out. What I was interested in also, besides, we all do that, and I think it's great. You have the certain show day prep. But the gentleman who is playing your father, what is his name? Fran Geinen. So Larry David was just talking about when he does usually whatever he's doing.
我不知道他是不是在说单口喜剧什么的。一旦有了观众，疲劳感就会消失，你知道的。然后我觉得在戏剧中，你依靠着他。他依靠着你。这种连接有望让大脑里那些“我演得怎么样？进展得怎么样？”的想法在某些时刻消失，对吧？这就是它的魔力所在。
I don't know if he does stand up or whatever. It's just the fatigue goes away once there's the audience, you know. And then I think in a play, you're holding on to him. He's holding on to you. And that connection can hopefully make the part of your brain going, how am I doing? How's it going? All that go away at times, right? That's the electricity of it.
如果你和搭档在场景中过于投入，以至于感觉令人兴奋，对吧，当你知道你们在产生连接，而且观众在和你们在一起时。这就是你为之活着的动力，对吧？是的，我是说，这就是现场表演的全部毒药。我是说，这就是我们一直在追寻的东西。那是你每次都在追求的高潮。即使你的准备没有达到你想要的效果，或者你吃得太多，你仍然总是拥有这种事情发生的可能性。
If you get so involved in the scene with your partner, that it feels exhilarating, right, when you know you're connecting and the audience is with you. That's what you live for, right? Yeah, I mean, that's the dope of the whole thing, of live performance. I mean, that's the thing we're chasing. That's the high you're chasing every time. And even if your prep doesn't go as well as you want or you ate too much, you still always have that possibility of that happening.
发生。是的。是的。而且，如果他们出错了，观众是不知道的。他们可能会忘词。你帮他们掩护。有一些小事情就像团队合作一样，做起来很有趣，直到最后有人说：嘿，你救了我。我刚才走神了。观众其实并不知道发生了什么，但你们知道，你落下了道具。有一些小事情让它保持活力，但这正是节目中那种有趣的团队合作，比如在演出中也是如此。我在演出时就遇到过这种情况。我演过一个外百老汇的剧，我和另一个女演员在舞台上。我们只在舞台上待了四行台词，因为我们互相看对方不顺眼。我们在等同一个男人。我们喜欢
happening. Yes. Yes. And also, if they get something wrong, the audience doesn't know this. They could miss a line. You cover for them. There's little things that are like teamwork things that are fun to do that you get through the end and someone's like, hey, you save me. I spaced out. And the audience doesn't really know what's going on, but you guys, you forgot a prop. There's little things that keep it alive. But that's kind of the fun teamwork of it all, like in a show also. That happened to me during a show. I did a a show off Broadway and me and this other actress were on stage. And we're only on stage for like four lines because we don't like each other. And we're waiting for the same guy. We like
同一个男人，我们在等他走进来打破这种紧张气氛。但他没有上台。他没来。他只是错过了出场。所以我开始即兴发挥，然后剧作家说：哦，天哪，我简直不敢相信人们会认为那些台词是我写的。那只是……那简直是糟糕透顶的即兴发挥。我说：我们能怎么办？我们就坐在那儿。没人上来。这是一个行为艺术，你坐在那里沉默十二分钟，等待他们去隔壁熟食店找到那个家伙。
the same guy and we're waiting for him to walk in and break the tension. And he didn't come on stage. He didn't come. He just missed his entrance. And so I started improvising, which then the playwright was like, oh my God, I can't believe people thought I wrote those lines. That was just It's like terrible improvisation. I'm like, what were we supposed to do? We're just sitting there. No one was coming on. It's an art piece of you sit in silence for 12 minutes waiting while they find the guy at the deli next door.
我喜欢那种有人没有把手机静音或者在打电话的时候。然后百老汇剧中的演员直接跳出角色。他穿着某种小丑服或者扮成熊。我会宰了你个王八蛋。你知道的，就是那套小丑服。这是现场直播。好了，珍娜，我问你的最后一个问题是，我喜欢你为《办公室》试镜时，艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones）作为选角导演，我们三个可能都在路上遇到过她。最棒的。
I like it when someone's didn't silence their phone or it's talking to the phone. And then the actor in the Broadway show breaks character. He's in some kind of clown suit or dresses a bear. I will kill you, motherfucker. You know, it's just that clown suit. It's live. Now, Jenna, my last thing for you is I like that when you audition for the office, Allison Jones, as a casting director, we probably all three have run into along the way. The best.
我喜欢那种有人没把手机调成静音或者在打电话的情况。然后百老汇演出的演员出戏了。他穿着某种小丑服或者熊的服装。我要杀了你，混蛋。你知道的，就那套小丑服。这是现场的。好了，珍娜，我要对你说的最后一件事是，我喜欢你为《办公室》试镜的那次，艾莉森·琼斯作为选角导演，我们三个可能都在路上遇到过她。最棒的。
Said, dare to bore me. I think that's interesting. Yeah, I read that. I like that because most people are trying to give you the biggest pizzazz of a lifetime in an audition. Well, I had been auditioning for Allison for about five years before the office. I got my first speaking role on a television show. It was Spin City, the Charlie Sheen Years, and I had three lines as a waitress.
她说，敢于让我觉得无聊。我觉得这很有意思。对，我读过那个。我很喜欢，因为大多数人在试镜时都想展现出一生中最耀眼的风采。好吧，在《办公室》之前，我大概为艾莉森试镜了五年。我在一部电视节目里得到了我的第一个有台词的角色。那是《城市滑头》，查理·辛时期的作品，我演一个女服务员，只有三句台词。
And then I would, she would bring me in for other little things. Sure. And finally, when it was time for her to cast the office, I had a good enough relationship with her that I could say, hey, Alison, do you have any advice? I really want this one. And she said, yeah, my advice is don't come in, Don't come in looking hot.
然后她会，她会叫我去试一些其他的小角色。当然。最后，当她要为《办公室》选角时，我和她有了足够好的关系，以至于我可以对她说，嘿，艾莉森，你有什么建议吗？我真的很想要这个角色。她说，嗯，我的建议是别盛装出席，别打扮得很惹火来面试。
Like, don't come in all done up. And by the way, usually the note was, okay, you're playing a pediatric nurse but like hot. Or like you're playing a school teacher, but like really hot. So like usually the note was look hot. Mortician, but hot. But super hot. Like she's really, really hot. And I'm like, okay.
就像，别打扮得花枝招展的。顺便说一句，通常的要求是，好吧，你演一个儿科护士，但要性感的那种。或者像你演一个学校老师，但要非常性感。所以通常的要求就是看起来很火辣。殡仪师，但要性感。超级性感。就像她真的非常非常性感一样。我就想，好吧。
So she was like, don't come in like looking hot. Don't come in with a bunch of makeup. Overdone, yeah. We want real people. And then she said, we're going to have you improvise during the audition. And my advice is dare to bore me. And I was like, okay, great. So I went in and I read the scene.
所以她的意思是，别打扮得很火辣来面试。别化着浓妆。过度打扮，对。我们需要真实的人。然后她说，我们在试镜时会让你即兴发挥。我的建议是，敢于让我觉得无聊。我就想，好吧，太棒了。所以我进去读了剧本。
And then Greg Daniels said, okay, we're going to improvise. I'm going to just ask you some questions as if I'm a documentary filmmaker. And I had that note in my head. And he said, do you like being a receptionist here? And I just paused and I said nothing. And then I said, no. And that's all I said. That's funny.
然后格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，好的，我们要即兴发挥。我会像个纪录片制作人一样问你几个问题。我脑子里记着那个建议。他问，你喜欢这里的接待员工作吗？我停顿了一下，什么也没说。然后我说，不。这就是我说的全部。真搞笑。
Because I thought it would be funnier to watch me think of all the things I wasn't going to say than to say any of them. And then also, though, she's like a deeply honest person. So she can't lie and say she does like. ticket, but she's also not going to say anymore. And I think that's what got me the job. Greg told me that's what got me the job. That is so cool. Dare to bore me.
因为我觉得看着我去想那些我不会说的话，比真的说出其中任何一句要搞笑得多。而且，她也是一个极其诚实的人。所以她不能撒谎说她喜欢。门票，但她也不会多说一个字。我想这就是我得到这份工作的原因。格雷格告诉我，这就是我得到这份工作的原因。太酷了。敢于让我觉得无聊。
That was... Dare to bore me. It was so scary. It's so scary to... Oh, because you want to just go for the fences. I know. It's so hard to just have restraint. That's like, for me, the hardest thing about acting is just holding in silence.
那是……敢于让我觉得无聊。太可怕了。太可怕了……哦，因为你只想全力以赴。我知道。要克制自己太难了。对我来说，演戏中最难的事就是保持沉默。
And then on the office, you really are working with people that are all doing it, and it's so fucking funny. It's amazing. It's just an amazing, amazing thing to have been a part of. It just, I still can't believe it. And just what it means to people, too. Like, that's so cool. I know that the office has gotten people through hard times in their lives. And, you know, once in a long ago, I fell down a set of stairs in New York at BudaCon. It was during like an NBC event. I was there with Fred Armisen, actually. actually. And I fell down this set of stairs and I broke my back in four places. And while I was recovering, I watched the Larry Sanders show. And it was like better than any pain medicine. So like the fact that I can like I can be part of something that is that for other people, like I know what it means to have a thing that like gets you through something. It's really cool. Wow, that's full circle because I believe that Ricky Jervais felt like he was influenced by the Larry Sanders show.
然后在《办公室》里，你真的是在和一群都在这样演的人一起工作，这太他妈有趣了。太棒了。能成为其中一部分，真是一件太了不起、太了不起的事情。我简直，我还是不敢相信。它对人们来说也意义重大。比如，这太酷了。我知道《办公室》曾陪许多人度过生活中的艰难时期。而且，你知道，很久以前，我在纽约的武道馆摔下了一组楼梯。那是正值某个NBC活动期间。其实我是和弗雷德·阿米森一起去的。其实是的。我从那组楼梯上摔下来，背部四个地方骨折了。在康复期间，我看了《拉里·桑德斯秀》。那感觉比任何止痛药都好。所以，我能成为对其他人有这种意义的事物的一部分，这种感觉……我知道拥有一个能陪你渡过难关的东西意味着什么。这真的很酷。哇，真是兜了一圈，因为我相信里奇·热维斯觉得自己受到了《拉里·桑德斯秀》的影响。
And then he does the British office and then you go to the American office and then you break your back and then you're watching Larry Sanders. I don't know where this keeps going, but it's something kind of cool about that. That was a show that's magic. We were both on it. Were you on it, David? We were on Larry Sanders. Also, we all worked with Greg Daniels, who is a shout out to him, who is a great writer that obviously. S&L.
然后他制作了英国版的《办公室》，接着你拍了美国版的《办公室》，然后你摔断了背，然后你正在看《拉里·桑德斯秀》。我不知道这会通向哪里，但其中有些东西真的很酷。那是一个充满魔力的节目。我们俩都在上面。大卫，你在上面吗？我们在《拉里·桑德斯秀》里。另外，我们都和格雷格·丹尼尔斯合作过，向他致敬，他是一位伟大的作家，显然。周六夜现场。
I remember when Greg Daniels and Conan O'Brien walked into the offices at S&L, fresh out of Harvard, looked like they were sophomores in high school, little haircuts, kind of nervous, looking around. Yeah, great. Yeah. And they were roommates, too. I know. It's amazing, really.
我记得格雷格·丹尼尔斯和柯南·奥布莱恩走进《周六夜现场》办公室的时候，刚从哈佛毕业，看起来就像高中二年级的学生，留着小发型，有点紧张，四处张望。对，太棒了。对。而且他们还是室友。我知道。真的太神奇了。
And those SNL years, you liked, it's like we were propped up by guys like that and Bob Odenkirk and Smigel. downy and frank yeah there's so many good writers it's kind of nice when and i'm sure you just do that you're not trying to get kudos about it but if someone says to you later because not everyone is really friendly when you walk into an environment like that and they'd say oh you were so nice to us i go really i was i think i was just like how you guys doing or something but some people were like more competition we don't need you you know it's a little it can be a little cold at s andl no one's really telling you where you should stand or what you should even do
在《周六夜现场》的那些年，你喜欢，就像我们被这样的人，还有鲍勃·奥登科克和斯米格尔支持着。唐尼和弗兰克，是的，有那么多优秀的作家，这挺好的，而且我确信你只是那样做，你不是在寻求赞誉，但如果有人后来对你这么说——因为当你走进那样一个环境时，并不是每个人都真的很友好——他们会说，哦，你对我们真好，我说，真的吗？我当时大概只是在想你们好啊之类的，但有些人会更有竞争意识，我们不需要你，你知道，在《周六夜现场》有时会有点冷漠，没有人真的会告诉你你应该站在哪里，或者你甚至应该做什么。
That's what we learned. A lot of people were like, they didn't even know. No one told them anything, you know, about the show. And they just had to figure it out for themselves. But anyway. Well, it's an interesting environment. I got to be on the show as part of Steve Kroll's monologue once. And I was, I mean, again, like I told you, I'm a Saturday Night Live groupie nerd.
这就是我们学到的。很多人都这样，他们甚至都不知道。没有人告诉他们关于节目的任何事情，你知道的。他们只能靠自己去摸索。但不管怎样。好吧，这是一个有趣的环境。我有幸作为史蒂夫·卡瑞尔独白的一部分上了这个节目。我是说，再次像我告诉你的那样，《周六夜现场》的追星族书呆子。
And so this was, I don't even remember what I had going on. like 24 hours notice, do you want to come fly in? And I was like, yes. I came in on a red eye. I was like anything. And to be in the bowels to like get to be there for the rehearsal. And then how like, oh my God, it really does change from the rehearsal. That was nuts.
所以当时，我都记不清当时我有什么安排了。大概提前24小时通知，你想飞过来吗？我说，好。我坐红眼航班来的。我说什么都行。能深入幕后，能去现场观看排练。然后发现，哦天哪，排练和正式演出真的完全不一样。太疯狂了。
And just it was so scary. And my line changed. And then the cue card changed. And then how we all went into Lauren's office. And you're like sitting on the floor like waiting to hear like what things. made it and what didn't and I couldn't believe I was invited I was like I'm just the I just have like one sentence in the opening monologue but I was like privy to all of the inner workings it was so awesome it is and then that night at the after party I I held Lauren Michaels focus for 30 solid
而且太吓人了。我的台词改了。然后提词卡改了。然后我们怎么都去了洛恩的办公室。你就像坐在地板上一样，等着听哪些内容入选了，哪些没有。我简直不敢相信我被邀请了，我说我只是，我开场独白里只有一句话，但我却能了解所有的内幕运作，太棒了。确实如此，然后那天晚上的庆功派对上，我霸占了洛恩·迈尔斯的注意力整整30
minutes. Whoa. And I still, to this day, it is one of my, my best, like, small talk moments ever. Because I'd met him many times. I had come and I saw when Christina Applegate hosted and when John Hamm hosted, I came as their guest and I would sit and I would run into it and shake his hand and all this sort of stuff. And, and, um, but for whatever reason at this particular after party, I got in a whole chat with him about how I like to prep for the apocalypse. And he was very interested in this topic. And we spoke for like a solid 25 minutes. And I wanted to keep talking to him.
分钟。哇。直到今天，这仍然是我最棒的、最棒的小聊天时刻之一。因为我见过他很多次。我来过，看到克里斯蒂娜·艾伯盖特和约翰·哈姆主持的时候，我是作为他们的嘉宾来的，我会坐着，然后会碰巧遇到他并和他握手，诸如此类的事情。而且，呃，但不管出于什么原因，在这次特别的庆功派对上，我和他聊了整整一聊天，内容是我喜欢如何为世界末日做准备。他对这个话题非常感兴趣。我们聊了足足25分钟。我还想继续跟他聊。
I wanted to keep going. But I knew that I had to say goodbye. Yeah. And I did it. I left at the right time. And I'm so proud of myself. That's interesting. And now I never want to speak to him again.
我本想继续聊下去。但我知道我必须说再见。是的。我做到了。我在恰当的时候离开了。我为自己感到骄傲。这很有趣。现在我再也不想跟他说话了。
will never speak to him again. I will not ruin it. Six years there, I didn't get 30 total. It was, I'm telling you, I'll never, I never, ever want to run into him again. That was a good subject matter for him. Something that he would be like, just doesn't talk about every day. You first have to make sure that you procure a fair amount of water in the event of apocalypse. I put Triscuits down there. I mean, did he respond at all? I mean, you really talked about your preparation for the apocalypse like for 30 minutes straight. For a good amount of time. But then we also talked about the movie The Edge, which is my favorite movie. And, you know, it's
再也不会跟他说话了。我可不想毁了它。在那里六年，我连总共30分钟都没有。我是说，我真的再也不想、再也不想碰见他了。那对他来说是个不错的话题。是他平时不会天天挂在嘴边的那种事。你首先得确保在世界末日来临时采购相当数量的水。我在地下放了脆饼干。我是说，他有任何回应吗？我是说，你真的连续30分钟都在谈论你为世界末日做准备的事情吗？有相当长的一段时间。但后来我们还聊了电影《势不两立》，那是我的最爱。而且，你知道，它是
a survivalist movie. I love movies where people have to survive things. I've seen it at least five times. And that's a movie. And we told Alec Baldwin that, that friends come over, a relative is, oh, let's watch a movie. And once in a while, I go, if you've seen The Edge, they go, no, I go, it's just kind of a surefire great entertaining film. No one cannot like it. Dana, what one man can do, another can do. That's from the movie. What one man can do, another can do. I'm telling you, that's gotten me through, like, big life moments. I love this movie.
一部生存主义电影。我喜欢人们必须在绝境中生存的电影。我已经看至少五遍了。那是一部电影。我们把这告诉了亚历克·鲍德温，朋友们过来，有个亲戚说，哦，我们看部电影吧。偶尔我会说，如果你看过《势不两立》，他们说，没有，我说，这是一部万无一失的伟大娱乐电影。没有人会不喜欢它。达娜，人能做到的，人也能做到。那是电影里的台词。人能做到的，人也能做到。我告诉你，这支撑我度过了许多生活中的重大时刻。我太喜欢这部电影了。
And so we talked about The Edge, which ended up leading into survivalist stuff, into prepping. And he was really interested in my currency plans. Like, what were my plans for currency during the apocalypse? Did I have gold bars? And you know what? To be honest, I hadn't thought of it. I hadn't gotten as far as currency. Funny, when I was there in the fall doing Biden, just behind his decks, I saw this whole duffel bag, you know, it's really big, you know, and then when he left to use the bathroom, it was just all this survival stuff in there.
所以我们聊了《势不两立》，这最终引出了生存主义的话题，引出了末日准备。他对我的货币计划真的很感兴趣。比如，我在末日期间的货币计划是什么？我有金条吗？你知道吗？说实话，我还没想到那一步。我还没考虑到货币那么远。有趣的是，当我在秋天去那里模仿拜登时，就在他的桌子后面，我看到了一个很大的帆布行李包，你知道，真的很大，你知道的，然后当他去洗手间时，里面全是这些生存装备。
He goes by and he pushes a wall and it spins around. He disappears down a slide. I want to be ready. He was influenced by my, by my prep. Tony Hopkins had that line, right? One man can do, another man can do. Is that Tony Hopkins? Yes, correct.
他走过去推了一下墙，墙转动了。他从滑梯上滑下去消失了。我想做好准备。他受到了我的，我的准备工作的启发。托尼·霍普金斯有那句台词，对吧？人能做到的，人也能做到。那是托尼·霍普金斯吗？是的，没错。
And Al, Al Bald. One was Al Ball one was great and that. So was Tony. I love people changed names. Jen, Jen was great on our pocket. Jen Fisher. Does anyone call you Jen? No, no one's ever called me Jen. Well, get ready for it. We have a lot of followers. By the way, people may not know. We're on the same network. It's almost like television now. So that's kind of cool. This is jury duty for Jen. And I just for people who are watching this or might want to see it. So are you in a studio somewhere? Yeah. I'm at your New York studios. Yeah, I'm here in New York this week. And so I came into the New York studio. And are you and Angela usually in different places when you do the podcast and sometimes
还有阿尔·鲍德温。阿尔·鲍德温在那部戏里很棒。托尼也是。我喜欢人们改名字。简，简在我们的播客里表现很棒。简·费舍尔。有人叫你简吗？不，从来没有人叫我简。好吧，准备好迎接吧。我们有很多粉丝。顺便说一句，大家可能不知道。我们在同一个网络。现在这几乎就像电视节目了。所以这挺酷的。这是简的陪审团义务。我只是为那些正在观看或者可能想看的人问一下。所以你是在某处的录音室里吗？对。我在你们的纽约录音室。对，我这周在纽约。所以我来到了纽约录音室。你和安吉拉做播客时通常在不同的地方，有时
together or always? No, we're usually together. Odyssey, our company that we both work for has a studio in Hollywood and we usually record there in person together. You guys are all set up at home. Like, you guys have cool setups. We don't go in person. We've been going in person. I kind of feel I need a background or something. It changes a lot. When I was not doing SNL, I was just in a hotel room doing it.
在一起，还是总是这样？不，我们通常在一起。我们两家都效力的公司奥德赛在好莱坞有一个录音室，我们通常在那里一起现场录制。你们都在家里设置好了。比如，你们有很酷的设备。我们不是现场录制的。我们一直都是现场录制的。我有点觉得自己需要一个背景什么的。变化挺大的。当我没在做《周六夜现场》时，我只是在酒店房间里录。
That's one of the advantages of this is that you can do it remotely if you have to. But David has a little studio. I just have this stupid mansion, yeah. But Jenna, thank you for joining us. Tell Angela, hello. and we appreciate your time. Oh, guys, I don't want it to end. I love you.
这是其中的一个优势，如果必要的话你可以远程进行。但大卫有一个小录音室。我只有这栋愚蠢的豪宅，对。但詹娜，谢谢你加入我们。代我向安吉拉问好，我们感谢你的时间。哦，伙计们，我不想结束。我爱你们。
I love you both. I love your podcast. This is so cool. This was a highlight for me. Well, everybody. Keep your eyes open for her play. I just enjoy talking to you. I just find I kind of thought.
我也爱你们俩。我喜欢你们的播客。太酷了。对我来说，这是个亮点。好吧，各位。请留意她的戏剧。我只是喜欢和你们聊聊。我只是觉得我有点……
You're always sweet and fun and just like you would think. Podcasters, actresses and all kinds of things you do. But if you do this, well, I think you do get a little more adept. at doing it, you know, conversing and letting it go where it needs to go and asking questions. So usually we have a podcaster on, it's an easy show, you know. Yeah, right? Because you know what you're hoping to get when you're doing it yourself. Yeah, and it doesn't have to be electric every moment.
你总是那么甜美、有趣，就像你想象的那样。播客主持人、演员以及你所做的各种事情。但如果你做这个，嗯，我想你确实会变得更熟练一点。做这件事，你知道的，交谈，让它顺其自然地发展并提出问题。所以通常我们请来一位播客主持人，节目就会很容易做，你知道的。对吧？因为你自己做的时候就知道你希望得到什么。是的，而且不需要时刻都充满电火花。
You don't have to push it. It just, it just is what it is, you know. If we seem rusty, it's because we've only done 2,000 of these. Okay. Ashleyne Avenue is the play and she's doing it in Chicago And it will be tickets on sale
你不需要强求。它就是，它本来就是那个样子，你知道的。如果我们看起来生疏，那是因为我们只做过2000次这种节目。好的。阿什琳大街是这部戏剧的名字，她将在芝加哥演出，门票将于
June 27th And it starts when in August you said? I think September 15th Okay September 15th All right Thank you very much Bye sweet art
6月27日开始发售，你刚才说什么时候开始来着？我想是9月15日。好的，9月15日。好的。非常感谢。再见，甜心。
Bye bye bye Thank you guys Don't hang up This has been a presentation Of Odyssey Please follow subscribe Leave a like a review All this stuff
拜拜拜。谢谢你们。别挂断。这是奥德赛呈献的节目。请关注、订阅，留个赞和评论。所有这些事情
smash that button, whatever it is, wherever you get your podcasts. Fly on the Wall is executive produced by Dana Carvey and David Spade, Jenna Weiss Berman of Odyssey, and Heather Santoro. The show's lead producer is Greg Holtzman. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
点击那个按钮，无论它是什么，无论你在哪里收听播客。《Fly on the Wall》由达娜·卡维和大卫·斯佩德、奥德赛的詹娜·韦斯·伯曼以及希瑟·桑托罗联合监制。该节目的首席制片人是格雷格·霍尔茨曼。感谢收听《办公室辣妈》。《办公室辣妈》是奥德赛呈献的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制片人是艾因斯利·布比科。奥德赛的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室辣妈》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉坦的《Ruppertree》。谢谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。